joe rogan made a bold statement on his
show
actually it was more of a passive
comment about censorship that i think
isn't as big of a deal to him but this
is what usually happens in the media
because the narrative coming out now is
that joe rogan threatens to quit his 200
million spotify deal if he has to walk
on eggshells and mind his p's and q's
now i think it's legitimate to say he's
threatening to quit and obviously
spotify's listening and we do know that
there have been episodes that have been
delayed or held back
on spotify since the latest outrage over
joe or whatever it is so i think it's
entirely possible joe is kind of doing a
you know passive state like he doesn't
want to call up spotify and say hey how
dare you or maybe he has i don't really
know but we you know so this is him
going on a show and saying hey if this
gets bad i'll be quitting so that's i
think that's that's an interesting story
to get into as it pertains to censorship
and uh what joe is willing to do
but i do think it's more interesting
that we've already seen episodes held or
deleted and there's a lot to talk about
because i wonder if joe's already at the
point where he's taking episodes down so
is he not already walking on eggshells
does it doesn't it already seem like
he's he's you know moving and the show's
changing
we'll have a conversation about that you
know and we contemplated which was more
newsworthy or a better lead because the
next one is hilarious cnn is reportedly
already cnn plus is reportedly already
failing on multiple fronts one there
have been some issues about technical
errors on cnn's new streaming platform
which launched launched yesterday but we
heard on day one of their launch they
were offering a 50
lifetime discount which is not
confidence building for people who are
watching it it seems cnn wasn't able to
actually get anybody to sign up
now it's being reported layoffs as early
as may because the launch day for cnn
plus was so miserable they don't think
they will be able to sustain their
investment
wow man talk about a crazy time in media
we've also got jon stewart going totally
woke and complaining about white people
bill maher
also going woke and saying republicans
hate black people which is funny because
he was referencing clarence thomas which
i'm pretty sure is like one of the most
popular conservative judges among
republicans especially and then we get
to disney there's the disney president
or a disney executive saying they want
half of all content to be
lgbtqia or racial minorities and there's
a lot to break down there and then of
course we can talk about you know
nuclear war and whatever and inflation
destroying your lives and uh you know
whatever might scare you but we'll talk
about media i guess joining us to
discuss this and also a nefarious plot
to destroy the congressional campaign of
robbie starbuck is robbie starbuck thank
you for having me i appreciate it you
want to introduce yourself yeah so
robbie starbuck for those of you who
don't know i'm running for congress in
tennessee middle tennessee district five
um you know and a big part of our
campaign has just been making sure that
we get rid of all of these career
politicians and that we get real people
in there to actually do the work of the
people and i think you know a big part
of that for us has been saying no to
every corporation that's knocked on our
door and said we want to give you money
or get a pack to funnel money to your
campaign we don't want it i'd rather put
in my own money and you know have a
grassroots operation than be one of
those people that answers to amazon and
dc so what you're saying is we need
politicians that represent
the will of the people exactly exactly
that was a strong lead into promoting
the song no what absolutely i might need
to ask you about taking that song for a
commercial you know you never know oh
yeah they're cool yeah yeah we also have
ian's hi everyone i'm back uh good to
see you all i hope you're all doing well
i'm doing extremely well myself i i uh i
received this in the mail and i want to
show it to you someone sent this to me i
was like what is this and i opened it
can you see from here it's a 20 it's a
twenty seven my joke it's a twenty sided
die but it's all twenties i think it's
twenty sided roll twenty yeah so there's
no losing here uh i hope you're doing
well i'm gonna ease back into this man
some crazy stuff happened this last
weekend and i wanna talk about it
especially will smith jacking that guy
on stage because that's totally
unexpected that guy chris yeah
chris rock phrasing totally fake i think
it's fine yeah the phrasing could be uh
cleaned up there
welcome i'm from the 90s yeah i'm also
here in the corner pushing buttons very
enjoyable we love having robbie and
we're excited to hear what he has saved
this evening but we do have a sponsor
before we get started ladies and
gentlemen head over to
surfinginternetsafe.com
and you can get a vpn of virtual private
network internet security from virtual
shield for 50
off for life protect yourself from cyber
attacks and hackers be it the government
or corporations trying to steal your
data surfing internet safe virtual
shield they got what you need their vpn
service is compatible with all devices
allows you to browse the web securely
safely and anonymously using their
global network of servers and private
ips it lets you browse the web
completely anonymously so the big name
isps and other third parties will not be
able to monitor your internet activity
and browsing history that might be
important for most people because the
joke is always that you know when when
someone's dying they're like delete my
browser history
because everybody knows you have a
secret that you're like you know looking
at stuff online that people you'd be
embarrassed by
when you're using virtual shield your
traffic is routed through their secure
and encrypted servers that means that
any restrictions censorship or blocks on
the internet are bypassed and it's
completely free for 30 days available
mac windows iphone ipad android or
chrome it does all the work for you
routes your internet through their
advanced encrypted servers personal
family and business plans are available
family plan includes 15 devices virtual
shield will completely encrypt your
wi-fi connection as well blocking
hackers and everyone else from accessing
your data
thank you very much virtual shield for
being a sponsor of the work that i've
been doing and and this show for years
now it's uh we are eternally grateful so
head over to surfinginternetsafe.com
if you would like to return the love to
to virtual shield and don't forget to
head over to timcast.com become a member
and you'll get access to exclusive
episodes of this show that go up monday
through thursday at 8 00 pm
i'm i'm listening i was just shaking up
my like my coconut water
and he's shaking he's like i'm like do
you need casting
i thought you needed to promote
something no no continue please yeah go
to timcast.com support our work uh smash
the like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
let's uh let's take this story about joe
rogan's passive comment and turn it into
a major news cycle event i suppose that
seems to be what everyone does but i
want to talk about censorship i want to
talk about what's happening with uh with
big media with youtube with cnn and i do
think it's worth launching off with this
so here's the story from dailymail joe
rogan threatens to quit his 200 million
dollar spotify deal if he has to walk on
eggshells and mind my p's and cues
following n word and vaccine
misinformation controversies
they say on on the uh journal experience
guest and mma fighter josh barrett 44
said he was worried he'd be judged for
every little thing quote
i will quit if it gets to a point that i
can't do it anymore where i have to do
it in some sort of weird way where i
walk on eggshells broken replied he's
been under fire in recent months this we
understand and now he's basically come
out and and made this statement joe also
came out and talked about chris rock
getting slapped in the face because i
think as a comedian everyone's like yo
that was not cool to smack chris rock
but we'll get into that stuff later
i want to point out first and foremost
as i said
is this just a passive comment you know
he's sitting there he's he's doing a
show and he's like i'd quit if it got to
that point because i i just want to
mention hasn't it got to that point
how many episodes now have been taken
down to the joe rogan experience do we
know how do you countless what's that
website do you know what that website is
i don't know what it is i'm gonna look
into it it's jre missing.com ridiculous
let me see if i can find it
jremissing.com yeah jerrymissing.com
there you go 113 episodes of the of the
joe rogan podcast are missing from
spotify and on february 4th 2022 a whole
bunch of episodes were taken down
including one with kyle kalinski where
kyle uh so everyone said the reason they
were taken down is because they're
episodes where joe said the n-word
kyle said that wasn't true right and he
was that he said in that episode though
he was talking about saudi arabia and
that's what he thinks so i i just gotta
i just gotta you know call like it is
man i think joe's a good dude i think he
does tremendous good but i'm also not
convinced he would quit i think that if
it really did came down to it joe would
not publicly say hey i'm being forced to
do something where was joe rogan's
statement on why magic news's episode
was withheld for three weeks
i think it was three weeks magic was
lighting up the internet on this this
magic hosts uh you know previously and
recently hosted a huge show on the radio
in london what is it um
what what's lbcc stand for one it's not
no it's not london company i don't like
british channel or something no it's not
that it was like conversation
something like that i don't know it's
biggest conversation london broadcasting
company originally no no that's not what
it stands for that's what this says it's
a radio show it means something else
because i said that to him and i was
like what is it like london london
broadcasting corporation he left he's
like no it's like something biggest
conversation but anyway imagine it was
not some random nobody so when he goes
and records with joe and talks about a
whole bunch of really important stuff
and then the episode doesn't go live for
almost a month and we hear nothing from
joe i gotta be honest as much i think
joe is a good dude and i think he does
stand up for a lot of people in good
ways i also think that if it really came
down to it he would not tell us he's
being censored he'd pull the episodes
passively mention them
you know not really give some some good
answer and then the reality is he'd
likely apologize well that's my
frustration a lot with you know the
totality of hollywood and entertainment
because you know for those who don't
know that that was where i started you
know i directed oscar winning actors
actresses some of the biggest music
stars and
you know being in that world i always
hear now that i'm in politics people go
oh was it really hard being like the
lone conservative and the truth is i was
not the lone person on that side the
reality is is there's a bunch of cowards
i was gonna say you're making
conservatives sound like howard's but
you said it before me they're a bunch of
cowards you know and i've said it to
their faces and some of these people are
the biggest stars in the industry
and they're just terrified of not having
easy access to capital it's not just
access it's easy access i could call out
some people right now yep because i
remember i was hanging out in la
and uh there was a bunch of trump
supporters that were uh doing some event
and there was some celebrity they saw
who they knew and they walked up and
they you know high five fist bump gave
hugs and then this this individual just
was like no no no no nobody can know
nobody can know he's like i'll lose i'll
lose everything yep yeah yeah yeah i
mean it's a big it's a big thing and you
know
that cowardice is going to cost us
something at some point and that's why i
think you know we've got to try to
motivate these people to show that you
can have success outside of this because
it does have a cultural impact and then
being able to see that you know honestly
even on levels like this that a show
like this can be as successful as it is
i would hope would give some sort of
inspiration to somebody like rogan to
say you know what and he's done this
before before he was with spotify so i
wish it would just sort of encourage
those people to say you know have some
courage go fight for something fight for
free speech fight for these values you
say you believe in because that
episode's incredible by the way
you know he went he went hard
machide how do you say that you imagine
it was one of ours it was one of the
most significant rogan episodes ever
which is why i i you know i always want
to cut joe slack he's got the biggest
podcast in the world he does tremendous
good he reaches so many people and i
know a ton of people who are like
left-leaning normies who have learned a
lot of truth and principle because they
watch joe absolutely but i'm going to be
honest when i look at this i can't come
out here in good conscience and be like
look i know joe i consider him a friend
and uh he's he's he's totally right
he'll stand up i'm like dude everybody
knows that episodes have been pulled
everybody knows that episodes have been
withheld first for or delayed everybody
knows joe's apologized for a variety of
things i think it would be dishonest for
for me to just be like oh yeah yeah
he'll definitely i don't think so man
you tell me if i'm wrong about this i do
feel like if you were in a similar
situation which i don't think you would
be in in the first place because i don't
think you want to be owned by anybody
but if you were in that situation you
would absolutely not stand for it like
if uh uh
so in in in this respect
i i have a different strategy on stuff
like this it would be an insane lie for
me to say that uh if youtube ever came
to me with censorship demands i would
refuse well of course not of course
there's been several circumstances where
i've been like i can't say a certain
name on the show so nobody say it right
so we set up timcast.com to make sure
that we could have our own space that
was isolated and protected that was
fortified
uh
joe's in that space yeah he's he's
literally in his fortified space he's
got a secure contract
and if he's willing to withhold shows on
with a secure contract now that i'm like
i mean
in that circumstance yeah i wouldn't do
it and and i got to say there are some
things i can't talk about because we do
work with other companies but we've
actually had uh people come to us and
try and cancel us you know with with
things we're doing on the website and
we've basically given them the middle
finger and good we we play a similar
game to like what uh what daily wire did
when harry's pulled out and denounced
them they were like we are going to put
everything that we would have we had to
promoting you to denouncing you to
rivaling you to challenging you so i'll
put it this way on youtube there's a
different story here joe i i think he
mentioned this but i could be maybe a
misremember it's been a while you know
you mentioned that like youtube there's
censorship
it you know on spotify he's going to be
free it's a it's a network deal and
already we're seeing there's still
censorship i do think it's fair to say
that if he stayed on youtube they would
have nuked him in two seconds for a
variety of agreed yes so
you know
what do we do well we here at temcas we
want to keep the youtube show going we
want to maintain as much reach as
possible for the the maximum good we can
do but we always we always promote the
website we have journalists on the
website and we want to make sure we're
leveraging the access to this you know
to youtube's network to promote a space
where we can have whatever conversation
we want to have if rogan watches he
should think about that those couple
words you used maximum good what is the
maximum good he could do because he he
has a very successful career you know we
actually used to live in the same area
um when we were both in calabasas
and you know he's incredibly successful
at this point what's the maximum good
you can do and it would be build your
own build it and they will come i think
you would have more people
and it'll have some longevity you know
you can bring in other people and then
allow a space where people can be free
yeah you know look uh
when we started expanding
timkastz.com when we started expanding
when i started expanding from just my
youtube show which was me sitting in a
room with a with a gopro pointing at my
face and now we're in this like six
figure studio
i was not rich i i i was like taking all
of the money that i was making and like
spending like crazy to like build and
grow and expand
joe
was rich before the podcast and was rich
during the podcast but this just go it
just goes to show there's different
kinds of people and and i'll stress this
again i mean the amount of good the dude
has done yeah for one thing the fact
that i'm even here and the success i've
had is is uh due partly to joe helping
me out i should say you know joe
expressed to me he was like nah look man
you came on my show you helped make
those episodes big and i'm like yeah but
look he didn't have to have me on
there's you know he really really helped
out everything we're doing that's
undeniable and so i think he has helped
create a whole lot through a sphere of
influence
i just get frustrated sometimes when i
see people of massive means not being
like yo if you've got
if you've got 10 million dollars 10
you could be like i'm gonna take i'm
gonna take a million bucks and i'm gonna
start
something seed something seed something
i i think it's fair to point out it's
very difficult to launch a podcasting
platform yeah i think joe could have
done it he could a hundred percent no
doubt
no doubt he could when it comes and it
would be massively successful it really
comes down to mental capital i think a
lot about this lately like if because we
talk sometimes like if you had 100
million dollars why don't you do
something with it why don't you create a
company because it is it requires your
time and your energy otherwise unless
you're going to do like we're kind of
chatting about this before the show
you're either throwing your money at a
group of people that you're just going
to trust and hope that it works out but
at that point rogan's not even involved
anymore i don't want to throw money down
a drain so like does he have the time
and the energy and the desire to run a
company because that is a lot of work a
lot of listening um
hours and hours yeah many many days you
know every day you don't work is
basically the company's gonna fall apart
that you're not there so yeah
i think there's enough people who
believe in him though in the message and
and you know what he's doing where you
could build out a team where that
wouldn't even be necessary i do think
that that's the case you know even even
if you look in that more corporate world
of entertainment there's people dying to
get out of these places if they were
given an opportunity to go run with
something that could be really you know
an open forum for freedom and for people
to do podcasts and similarly sort of
just have no rules it's hard
you know i'll i'll say that it is not
easy
everything we're doing um
you get to the point where
people really need to understand this
about companies once you reach like 50
employees i say like because it varies
from state but federally a whole bunch
of crazy restrictions and regulations
kick in all of a sudden now you're
dealing with uh infiltrators i'd love to
just you know hire everybody but what
happens if you hire antifa yep what
happens if joe's like i'm gonna launch
my own thing and then you get one person
who's like i only need six months and
then i can plant that seed and nuke
everything from it's difficult yeah and
you'll get people who will do it you'll
get people who act like your best friend
and their only interest is just
extracting as much as they can from the
system and watching it burn down and
then they'll spend all their time just
complaining about you and talking about
how you were a bad person if you did
everything for them it's nightmarish
it's the same thing with campaigns by
the way political campaign same thing i
mean you get the same deal with
political infiltrators wanting to get in
things like that so you have to keep a
very tight-knit group and it's a bummer
i i want to i want to just kind of uh
make sure i stress the point
joe's not obligated to do anything and
at this point he's done so much good
yeah
the the dude could turn his show into a
cooking show and i feel like he had a
great run man yeah yeah great no
absolutely true but this is the thing
about great people is you expect and
want greatness all the time and you push
them
to be the best version of what you think
they can be right and that's a healthy
thing that's what a real friend does too
a real friend doesn't just clap for you
and pretend you're always doing good a
real friend's gonna go
you need to go and try to level up and i
think that's you know at the core of
anybody sort of saying this that
appreciates him is we're saying level up
man you have it in you you can level up
and you can take a stand that is going
to be powerful i also wonder just you
know look obviously we're not afraid of
offending leftists i just don't care and
i wonder if joe's mentality is more so
there are people who are on the left who
just don't know
and you've got to be able to reach them
somehow i can respect that i can respect
that i'm not saying that's exactly what
he's doing but i certainly respect
varying degrees of trying to reach
people because i'm at the point where
it's like look we're going to talk about
the truth we're going to we're going to
we'll we're typically respectful and the
members only stop by timcast.com i was
swearing a lot yesterday yeah swearing
at ron perlman because that dude is he's
crazy crazy i actually tried to watch
that twitter video he made and i had to
shut it off twice out of fear like he
scares me because i've seen him in so
many movies i mean you can kind of
almost see a mug shot in it you know if
you just if you look hard enough you can
see his future mug shot because
something's gonna something's gonna
crack the guy like one eye was like down
why does he do that thing where he like
he smashes his chin you know what i mean
like i don't know instead of instead of
filming a video and being like hey
all of these photos and videos are of
him pointing down it's so weird mashing
his face so he looks crazy and like
donnie boy especially because like as a
director you know
actors like him have been blocked out so
many times where they know the blocking
they know how they look in front of a
camera like he's he's camera aware he
knows what is going on and he does that
intentionally okay you know the greatest
thing ever would be is if like ron
perlman comes out in like a few months
and then he has a whole collection of
all of the videos and photos he's posted
and then he just tells everybody he's
like i hope i made you laugh because it
was the funniest thing ever i gotta be
honest like watching that
out of the context of politics is one of
the funniest things ever
he's a meme where people like show a
picture of his face all smashed and like
saying crazy things i mean and it's also
like it's just an extension of the
craziness of the left right now where
literally all of them have to make sure
they go
gay
gay
gay
as if all of us are like oh how to call
the police
this person just said the word again
this this is illegal now
the bill doesn't stop it from happening
ridiculous let's let's let's talk about
the uh the something else that's that's
that's funny we'll have a good laugh
today we have this tweet from suraj
hashmi
uh cnn plus it's a collection of of
images posted by siraj cinon plus tweets
today a historic day for us as we launch
cnn plus our streaming platform that
brings you the stories of our world
anytime you want
what
what was a recent news worth newsworthy
first for you now a quick question did
cnn get their own emoji on twitter
they paid for that right right now here
we go thank you siraj for this
the very next day
breaking cnn plus employees bracing for
layoffs possibly as soon as may amid
projections of lackluster sales of new
streaming channel see a new streaming
channel cnn employees say new streaming
channel could be merged into larger
discovery plus as early as may unless
subscriptions pick up uh and then
shocker pick up 130 i don't know check
this out check this out though from
sagar and jetty
cnn plus already showing no confidence
in their product throwing away subs at
discount rates to fake their initial
sign up numbers shows how worthless the
product is book clubs and parenting
advice from personalities you can
already get for free on cnn garbage
cnn tell us how you really feel on day
one of cnn's new service we're offering
50 off for life
now look i understand if you know
someone does like a promo read and the
advertiser says
we'll do a discount for your audience
because we're trying to attract new
people to come and sign up this is day
one of cnn no confidence well this is
what's really funny okay
is i want you to just imagine something
there was a table like this one that
we're at right now and there were a
bunch of people around it and they all
thought it would be a really good idea
and they thought that people would pay
for
access to more brian stelter and more i
can't even say with that and more don
lemon okay
these people are crazy there's no other
way to put it they are absolutely off
their rocker insane nobody wants to pay
for this and anybody who does
that's going to be a list that you want
in the future because they belong in a
mental institution okay i i genuinely
wonder how many people that signed up
for their service though so i'm
wondering if they'll release those
numbers or if they have i don't know oh
no way if it's really low they probably
won't do it i just want to point out to
all of our members at timcast.com
you get a variety of shows mostly you'll
get monday through thursday our members
only show it's a half an hour long or so
sometimes longer because we'll have
people talking about crazy stuff and we
go for a long time and we also have the
green room show which is uh fridays it's
in the in the green room hanging out
with these personalities we had you know
jeremy boring we also have um conspiracy
shows and stuff that are more seasonal
we don't produce nearly as much as cnn
does you know their their thing is but
people actually want to watch you that's
the difference
it's true but the point i'm making is
it's ten bucks for teamcast.com because
that's about what we need to charge to
for one you know produce all these shows
and continue to expand you know maybe
once once you have weight substantially
more subscribers you lower the price you
know it can go down the more people who
sign up
cnn lowered the price before anybody
even had a chance to sign up but one
member at timcast.com
is creating the cultural influence of
three members of cnn cnn plus 100 so
that that's what i think is is
significant here and they're struggling
and they're going to be laying people
off and you know what good riddance to
uh to a bad problem well i think i told
lydia this
you know so i've been on you know pretty
much every big show i've been on tucker
and all these other places the one show
that i've been on where i've had more
people come up to me than anything
is actually this one that seems crazy to
me it is weird and i'd never expected it
you know i knew we'd get some you know
because you always get some from
different shows
i always thought tucker would be the
biggest you know because he has just a
really rabid audience and i've been on
there a lot so i would especially think
that it would be from there but there's
so many people who just randomly come up
to me and are like hey i saw you on tim
pool he is amazing the show's amazing i
love lydia
and then they leave you out yeah i'm
just like
that guy
it smells like it's a long-haired guy
it's the form it's long form because you
can sit here and people get to know you
yeah they're like they know you like i
think that that actually might be what
it is is the recognition long term if
you sit with somebody for an hour you
remember them if you really get into a
conversation with them but if you sit
with them for a four minute hit on
tucker or something like that if you're
interested maybe you remember if you're
not then it's just another talking head
on tv yeah
it's it's one of the reasons why i
stopped
going on fox yeah you know they started
hitting me up more and more and then
after a certain point i was just like
why yeah i mean no offense
not trying to drag them because the guys
who were trying to book me were nice but
it's just like i honestly have no
incentive to to to do a three-minute
spot on your show the first uh 20 30
years of my life was in the
entertainment industry as an actor for
age 15 to 30 i was like i'm gonna get to
the oscars one day and i'm gonna i'm
gonna have my moment of three minutes
where i get to tell the world the right
info that i need to deliver and then
youtube appeared and all of a sudden it
was like every day is an oscar speech
this completely the industry's
completely shifted yeah it's just
totally and this brings me back to the
cnn whoever's running this business is
not savvy either they they they put they
gambled on this they gambled the
livelihoods of their employees on this
on and on on extra chris wallace content
okay
chris wallace but think about being
chris wallace yeah and being so
inept that you were like going to cnn
plus is a good idea
well this is actually you know i feel
almost a little bad for him because this
is one of those generational things like
at his age some you know younger
executive comes and says we're going to
do this cool new streaming platform and
you know he's like
well that's the new thing i mean i guess
people are doing streaming so sure and
has no concept of the fact that nobody's
going to pay for this from cnn plus yeah
but nobody cares
fox that's the problem oh yes 100
spineless losers he's already sponsored
you know i can tolerate
opinion but when you're calling for
insurrection
but when you have certain opinions then
i can't tolerate it anymore so one of
the responses to suraj was
about cnn plus that sucks are we
celebrating this people are losing jobs
yes we are because the people who would
work at cnn the people that were exposed
by project veritas the ones who were
saying we don't do news anymore they
want to destroy your life these are
people who are like don't blame me i
know cnn's bad but i'll certainly take a
pitchfork and chase you out of town if
they tell me to no i'm i'm sorry dude
when when when we talk about cops when
we talk about policing and i say i'm not
going to defend cops when they're
shutting down mom and pop shops over
covet the police departments don't
deserve my support if they're going to
arrest some lady over you know opening a
salon or a guy for having opening his
gym you think i'm gonna sit here and
stand for the people at cnn who are
either willfully or ignorantly
supporting that that crooked corrupt bs
no way dude they should all be fired
yeah they you know i have
no sympathy no empathy for that crowd
they get fired i'm gonna celebrate every
single time um on a side note in our
area down in tennessee our officers did
not allow any of that coveted stuff to
happen period and that is the reason why
you're seeing this massive exodus out of
blue states and out of areas where the
police do allow this stuff in our areas
the police protected the people which is
what they're supposed to do you know and
they protected our rights i i think
that's an important distinction too
because i've been like you know i've
said you know abolish the police fine
you know democrats if they want it they
can get they can take whatever they want
i'll call their bluff and with the cops
we're shutting down people over covet
you know what fine get rid of them but i
should issue a clarification what we're
really talking about is the problem the
problematic police are in big cities
that are run by 100 percent appointed
lot of these places and blue state
troopers 100 i mean you see some of them
reporting on their own officers for just
going and doing investigative work you
know that's happened in a number of
cases where they're running something
down and they're like no you can't do
that we haven't had a whole lot of
conversations about abolishing the south
dakota police who you know didn't go in
and and harass people and shut them down
in fact south dakota did a pretty good
job and in florida they put up
billboards i think there was one out
here that said you know it was basically
like come be a cop in florida so you
know we're in we're in western maryland
and we're in west virginia but over on
the maryland side they're like hey if
you don't want to be a cop here because
what's going on it come down to come on
over so so the issue really is you know
what
it's not the police
it's the politics michael malus would
have some choice words there but uh yeah
it's the politics it is well no i know
you know
the sheriffs there really are making a
difference in this country are the ones
who go out there and say i want you
armed i want you to exercise your second
amendment i want you to carry i want you
to be a part of this service to the
community to make sure we live in a safe
place where i live in tennessee you
don't worry about violent crime you
don't worry about any of these issues
because number one people are worried
you might be caring but number two they
know that our sheriffs don't put up with
anything like that and beyond that when
the government comes in and intrudes and
this is the most important point when
the government oversteps
they don't say my job is to serve the
government they say my job is to serve
the people
and that is the really important
distinction that's when you go from it
being you know police to being you know
essentially state actors
and that's where i'd have a problem the
people who go and they're saying i'm
gonna go defend whatever joe biden's
edict is
even if it's illegal
that's not something i want any part in
but if you're going and you're doing
what was intended
you can't replace that you know we need
more and more of that sort of you know
outlook
yeah when cnn people just to reiterate
lose their jobs i'm not going to shed a
tear over it nope yeah i think uh when
it comes i'll throw them a party like
a big partner party yeah they can come
and it'll say learn to code they want
like the federal reserve's huge on job
creation programs they're all about the
job economy where you dig a hole and
then they're going to get that guy to
come fill the hole back up and then
they'll pay that kind of digger and
they'll pay you fake money and keep you
paying taxes and and owe interest so
they they make money off of your toiling
around with these jobs well that this is
at that point shattering a worthless
company is not necessarily losing yeah
you're losing jobs it might actually
benefit the society if you have a
company that's doing bad things you want
those jobs to be gone bravo sir hard 20
right there from ian cnn is damaging
society they're not helping it so when
they're like we have to lay off these
people i'm just like um if you hired
somebody to go and riot with antifa i
would appreciate it if they were laid
off yeah cnn is the mental equivalent of
antifa 100 they're causing insane
political damage they're the reason
people like ron perlman smash their face
into their chest and go daddy boy
don't say gay because the dude doesn't
actually know what's going on because he
watches cnn cnn's owned by disney right
yep this is so disney probably no no no
no they're not open
yeah they're not owned by disneyland
they're not owned by nation
cnn's operated by warner media yeah yeah
it's uh espn that's owned by disney i
was getting that stuff abc all these
other companies owned by disney operated
by 18t so it's warner
this is like the news arm of warner of
that company so they just they just got
sold i think they just got sold to
warner right because i know there was a
recent sale
um
yeah because i think 18 at t owned them
yeah but at t is owned by warner or no
they're owned by dish so like like
whoever sold it they got out quick they
got out at the right time
and they're just gonna subsidize it you
think warner's just gonna subsidize this
thing to death basically until it no one
until it's completely it's annihilated i
had i was wondering about this because
cnn's ratings are so abysmal i'm just
like what why would someone buy cnn i
don't get it i really don't i don't even
want the brand anymore the brand's
brand's popular though it is super
popular with like normie internationally
yes that's the issue so what happens is
uh cnn on youtube their youtube ratings
tripled
from like 25 million a week to 80
million a week when the war happened for
about three weeks their viewership was
ripple well no it's regular people who
are like hey some big news thing
happened i better search cnn for it but
it's why they're motivated to make
stories happen
that go in that direction because they
love war right it helps the ratings
advertisers pay more you know good
things happen in their view
wow i mean that's very much like a
fireman getting paid to put out fires
and then end up lighting their own fires
to get paid i mean there should not be
an incentive to make money for a news
organization on bad news did you see
ryan long uh and danny paulus chuck's
bit about the antifa window repair yeah
yeah they were like they simultaneously
go out with antifa writing and smashing
windows but then also offer our window
repair service yes yes so you know
that's kind of how it works a little bit
like that exactly well i mean they're
cheerleading at this point some of the
stuff you know we were listening um in
the car um and i think they were
replaying see it was either cnn or msnbc
in the car
and um these people were totally
ludicrously pushing for war you know you
couldn't be more
sort of
profane in terms of your divorcedness
from the human side of this that people
are going to have to die for this you
know but on their side of things they're
like we want to keep this going for
ratings thank you for using the word
profane i've been thinking about how
about how you don't have to use swear
words to be profane certain behaviors
and actions are pro they're more profane
than curse words you know they really
are if you're sitting there and you're
advocating to send a bunch of young men
and women to die in some foreign country
that they have no business in that's
profane that's more profane than
somebody using the f word or whatever it
is that is profane because you're
divorced from the reality of war and
loss and pain that normal people feel
and if you're divorced from that you're
divorced from everything that matters
let me pull up this story we'll get
we'll start gonna get into more hard
politics it's from the daily mail two
russian fighter jets that violated
swedish airspace earlier this month were
equipped with nukes
with the aim of scaring stockholm
you know
it's certainly a story you could lead
with for a show like oh russia deployed
nukes at this point i am desensitized to
to these stories and we talked about it
yesterday vladimir putin reportedly you
know travels to nuclear bunker and as
we're getting into it i'm just like yo i
am i am desensitized to this they have
fear-mongered and screamed and banged on
things to the point where i'm like
whatever dude i got a bucket full of
beans
i'm not gonna cry and complain about it
and what do we even say when every day
they're trying to push some some you
know ukraine war joe biden like well you
know what's sad is the minute i saw that
i i didn't believe it because you know
i'm just kind of at that point where i'm
numb to it and i feel like we've been
told so many lies by the same people for
so long and every time you bite and
believe them you end up really
regretting it i mean and so i my first
question is what's the intelligence on
that who who said that this is the fact
you know yeah who knows what their aim
was i mean you'd have to have russian
intelligence confirming yeah you would
have to or have some sort of visual
confirmation i didn't read the story so
i don't know what they're saying is
backing up this claim but they're just
reporting it it's them it's their their
their their intelligence yeah and i have
no i have no respect for it at this
point you know there's there's nothing i
can
say except for that i you know you it
can't even assume it's true it has
emerged it has emerged emerged from
where
this is like the loch ness monster
is this company daily mail like a shock
content because i i see
interesting stuff come out of daily mail
it's sort of people don't report
joe threatens and it's like well i mean
he was warning i thought it was more of
a warning but they they phrased this as
a threat they're a little bombastic yeah
okay that's a little bombastic but
there's real there's real stuff there
yeah sometimes i think they don't go far
enough in how they describe things
sometimes i think they frame it wrong
sometimes i think they go too far yeah
but you know that is what it is is that
newsguard give a hundred no not a
hundred i mean maybe actually well see
that's the thing that i try to teach my
own kids about consuming media and news
in general is that they need to do what
tim just did
you know like critically think about
what each one of these places you're
reading from actually does what do they
do what are the mistakes they make so
that when you're consuming the
information you can do so in a manner
where you can kind of parse out
this might actually not be wholly
accurate but they're pretty good with
this stuff so that's probably true and
then go to somewhere else that is good
with the stuff they're not good with and
you can kind of fuse it together for
a real understanding of what you're
probably getting you know real though
let's be real
if right now i got a cnn alert on my
phone or
a video from cnn went on all the tvs or
wherever and it was brian stelter
himself
saying ladies and gentlemen a nuclear
missile was fired from russia and is
currently heading towards the north to
to towards the united states i'd believe
it
if if cnn came out on tv and brian
sutter said an icbm has been fired and
it's being tracked and headed towards
the us
i would believe it well i should put it
this way i would act as though it were
true is a better way to put it
i don't know you know
if that potato went on tv and said my
birthday was february 27th i probably
wouldn't believe it it's different even
though it is my birthday but but that's
different
like we're talking about
a missile headed towards the us maybe
jake tapper i'd believe it if it was
jake tapper maybe i'd believe it it was
like he wouldn't lie about that he'd lie
about a lot of other stuff but maybe not
that i like that you phrased it as you
would act as though it were true not
necessarily believe in facebook but take
evasive action if someone's going to go
on national tv make that claim that's a
big enough claim for me personally to
take seriously regardless of where it's
probably wise probably wise in the case
of a nuke i'll give you that but if he
said it about a virus i'd be like no i'm
not not buying any non-immediate thing
i'm not going to make a snap i'm not
going to jump to activity because of
what cnn just told me yeah i mean if if
brian stelter you know posted a twitter
video and he said
intelligence was reporting and icbm
headed towards the east coast i'd be out
the door and i'd be like let's go to our
secure location and act as though it's
true
and then if he comes out later and he's
like whoopsie i was watching war games
or what was that what's that movie
matthew broderick yeah war games yeah
talk about burying the lead i'm pretty
sure you just confirmed you have a
nuclear bunker well i didn't say nuclear
bunker but we have a security i mean you
kind of you kind of inferred possibly or
implied nuclear bunkers but we have a
bunker i'm not entirely sure can
withstand a nuclear blast would you guys
ever move into one of those bunkers
where they launched like space shuttles
out of and stuff you mean
yeah like live there
no i have a beautiful farm so i'd stay
there i'm staying i'm staying on the
farm what about under your farm
in a nuclear war oh absolutely i could
so i could survive anywhere if i had my
wife my kids and my my dogs i'm happy it
doesn't matter where i am you can buy
nuclear uh icbms uh uh silos missile
silos they're not necessarily nuclear
scientists and there's like 16 floors
yeah that's what i was thinking of but
you if you set up the farm up top you
you go down and you have this big
cylindrical uh man i could live with
that i got to live with it it looks like
really cool but i think that's more
fantasy when you get there it's all
grungy and like yeah
it sounds like a great idea till you
smell it right
i know and you get vitamin d
deficiencies yeah depressed
my gosh man these these dystopian sci-fi
movies where people are in like this
underground room with tv screens for
windows
and they're like we're there basically
you know what's amazing how many people
have vitamin d deficiencies i know
that's totally off topic but i was just
talking about that with somebody the
other day it is incredible the number of
people who don't get the right stuff
that their body needs i was also like if
you could somehow get sunlight
underground with mirrors
lose fidelity on every time it bounces
off the mirror so you have to use like
sound to guide the light and you might
be able to guide light down tunnels with
sound so you could like have daylight
underground with sound
sound waves can can uh guide photons
without interference as much as
interference as they found with matter
it's got to be an immense amount of
energy i'd imagine right probably i'm
sure i don't know that much about it use
mirrors and i don't want to take away
from your vitamin d talk because that's
super i've actually been taking a
vitamin d supplement yeah me too
store lately vitamin d and vitamin k i
think it is from jones himself mr jones
mine's for my doctor mine's for my
doctor but it's uh it's therapeutic
because i feel like people need to
really boost this stuff it gives you so
much energy makes you feel so healthy
you know i'm not making a go talk to
your medical person about it you know
i'm telling you
but if you're not getting out and
getting enough sunlight yeah it's so
good for you oh my gosh i was just in
washington state over the weekend and
the sun was amazing because it's not
like a des it's kind of a desert it's
like a mountain desert man that's
sunlight just non-stop yeah i would
highly recommend if you haven't been on
this vitamin d is underrated big time
big time underrated people you get sick
you know i remember when i was uh
younger i'd ask people like how come you
don't really see like
pets getting sick as often as people do
yeah and maybe it's not true for some
people maybe you get a dog with sick all
the time but i remember growing up our
dog was almost never sick with anything
and it's like well maybe because the dog
doesn't interact with other dogs and
humans direct other humans that's a good
story when dogs do weird stuff too like
sometimes you'll find them like nibbling
on a rock or something like that it's
because they actually can kind of search
out what they need and they'll get the
minerals somehow they're going to try to
find it and their body just knows you
know and i think that's why you see that
you know they're they're they're funny
little furry creatures they're smart
they can smell
cancer they can smell strokes think
about how incredible that is dogs can
smell sniff out cancer that's crazy wow
incredible yeah oh wow i wonder what
that or smelling the stroke before it
happens yeah or seeing a seizure wow
yeah there's videos where like someone's
about to seize their epileptic and they
catch them yeah the dog will jump on
them and then lay down and then they'll
be like uh oh and then they'll start
yeah unless it's the dog causing the
seizure oh yeah well that's that's a new
conspiracy i haven't heard that one it's
the word god spelled backwards you think
that's on purpose
well they're god's gift to us you know
so maybe maybe that's his way of letting
us know this is my gift to you because
there's nothing better than dogs we've
got great danes and they're the best
animals anybody who's ever like been
confused about what type of dog to get
get a great dane they're the best even
in an apartment they don't love exercise
as much as people would think they're
couch potatoes but they will give you so
much love
i have kind of a i don't have a hate
relationship not a love hate that's a
little extreme i got bit by a dog when i
was a bait like six i went it was
playing with it was eating and i got
close too close to it and it jumped up
and bit my face and ripped off i had to
get stitches and like it was really
traumatic so i've kind of had like a
distrust of dogs in general like i don't
i think they're psychopaths that was in
fact actually a democrat in the dogs
they were just dogs yeah no it's a
democrat in a dog suit so you're
distrusting the wrong person who's no
longer a democrat yeah
it was a young adam schiff i think a
joke by the way
once you learn how to like the dog's
language and you know don't get your
face next to it while it's eating if you
know some basic dog things i think
they're phenomenal oh they're fantastic
like our dogs i i was telling lydia
earlier actually like i trust my dogs
more than humans you know with my kids
there's certain people where i was like
if you had to leave them with the great
dane or that person who would you leave
them with and i'm like probably a great
dane most of the time you know they do
they do the job a little bit better
kind of crazy how we went from two
russian fighter jets with
dogs
of dogs and families well somehow we
went to vitamin d and then dogs and
living underground nuclear war is that
what this because you're going to need a
dog babysitter in nuclear war if you're
in a bunker just so you can get five
minutes also vitamin d supplements yes
yes you're definitely going to need
those we really wrap that up i think
this is all no okay
five fear propaganda all the all the war
junk i've heard that is is ukraine
actually gonna succeed don bass in the
eastern region that's what they're
saying i think they have to for this to
end you know i think that's where it's
was it that russia's seeding those back
to ukraine no no no no definitely not no
they're not going to see and the media
keeps reporting how russia is losing
but then how zelensky saying okay
we're gonna make concessions and give
you what you want
i do think that's where we're headed i
think probably two three weeks they'll
have a final deal that's just my you
know not based on any intelligence or
anything else just my my gut
feeling on this in that situation there
i think they're going to have to give
that area up because in reality well
russia wants a buffer
and you know they're not going to stop
making everybody's lives hell until they
get that buffer and i think that with
the administration we have they know
we're toothless we're not going to do
anything you know they're just going to
go and take what they want let's get
into uh some more hard politics though
so you're running for office robbie
where are you running for office and for
what office are you running tennessee in
the fifth congressional district this
almost looks like a story that might be
in my race
so uh you the big story around you is
that uh you're endorsed by trump right
no no no no he noticed the other he
endorsed the other one yeah and people
got very angry about it
yeah wrong
wrong very wrong you know love the guy
but um i think he actually did not
realize that this was the race i was in
when he made an endorsement the big
story was that it appears the it's the
republicans right they're trying to stop
you from being able to run for office so
they're trying to stop morrigan and
initially were trying to stop me too but
um they didn't realize how long i had
lived in the state so this bill that
they passed actually doesn't apply to me
because i've been a resident of
tennessee over three years
by the time of the election which is
what the amended law is so let's break
this down for us like you're running for
office how does it happen that they're
trying to block you from being able to
run for office well basically and you're
like you're like a trump supporter like
populist yeah well i think that's that's
the problem right is that i don't answer
to them i have no favors that i owe
anybody and that's the most dangerous
thing in politics is somebody running
who doesn't owe anybody favors
um you know so there's a lot of sort of
people who've been there for a long time
in the political establishment who are
very threatened by this guy showing up
out of nowhere crushing it in polls
having hundreds to thousands of people
at every event
and they're just like what the heck is
going on here we may have a problem on
our hands because if he's able to do
that then he could turn those people out
in races that we're in you know and i
think that's where the mental calculus
goes but then you know morgan came out
too and trump endorsed her and i think
they kind of felt a similar way with her
but a little different it wasn't so much
the populist fear but more so the fear
of like hey you're not from here you
know this this should be from for
somebody from here you know
and i think it's a little wrong-headed
you know i understand the instinct some
of them have because you want somebody
to represent the district who actually
has the state's interests in mind and
who understands the people and i agree
with that but when you look at what they
did here it's just the same sort of
disgusting you know sneaky politics that
people hate where you know you play by
the rules and if you're winning then we
change the rules it's like wall street
bets you know like if you're winning
suddenly it's like no no the rules need
to change and now you need to win by
these rules and what they changed is you
were saying before that they have a law
that says you have lived in the state
for three years three years until
election day and so for the people who
don't know the difference between the
races and stuff because it is a little
confusing in like house rep races you
can have those qualifications because
the state it's a state office the state
gets to set the qualifications for
federal office though for u.s congress
which is what i'm running for or for
senate um on the senate side or house
side of congress
you cannot do that as a state you know
at least constitutionally it's there's a
qualifications clause it's very clear
you have to be 25 years old and um you
know there's nothing about you needing
to be a resident of the state for x
amount of years you just need to be a
u.s citizen um and so that's where i
think they got it wrong with this i do
think it's a matter of does somebody
want to challenge it in court or not and
i don't know if they'll want to i don't
need to because it doesn't affect me but
um i think some people have a mindset
where they say states should get to
decide this sort of thing and if they
have that mindset maybe they walk away
from the race you know and say all right
i'll try to do something else but you
know if they were doing it to me and it
did affect me i would fight like hell i
i do see
the purpose of a bill you don't want
some random person you know maybe
somebody who was i don't know a governor
of uh what massachusetts or something or
or whatever like
a spokesperson for some
you know like a former governor like
flying to another state and then running
for senate or something like that you
know what i mean like he's like you
don't live here you don't really
represent us but i suppose the the
response i typically get from people
typically get is people can vote for
whoever they want exactly well this is
what my argument is and it's kind of
counterintuitive because you know i'm
almost shooting myself in the foot i
maybe shouldn't say this but even though
it doesn't affect me
i have a principal problem with this
like just if i'm being consistent with
my values my morals
i think this is wrong if we care about
an election integrity we should care
about people deciding elections i don't
want to boot somebody from a race
against me and beat them by proxy
because they got kicked out i want to
beat them on election day with people
voting for me more often than they vote
for them you know and that's how it
should be in our elections you should be
able to count on that that you're gonna
be able to get the real choices but
there's so much dirty dirty there is
it's a dirty dirty business and and
that's i talked about this with a couple
members actually this week and there's
no business like this where you're
expected to stab your friends in the
back on a constant basis
did
why would you want to be
in in congress well so for me
it's one of those things where i'm
looking at it from a state of not what
is good for me but a state of function
of what's good for my kids and i
realized that if we continue this same
pattern of having these career
politicians same lawyers from same
schools you know same sort of sets of
values and we keep sending them there
we're living the definition of insanity
this is just the same thing over and
over again and have we not learned the
lesson so i said you know what i have
nothing to lose we're gonna go try and
we're gonna run a campaign that is
everything that i believe in and i'm not
gonna owe anybody anything and it's sort
of like
for me i look back and i think back to
when i first got super engaged in
politics and it was ron paul
and i say what would have happened to
our country had ron paul become
president i'm just imagining everyone
holding hands and singing under a
rainbow everyone's pockets bursting with
cash and guns gold
guns and gold
guns and gold probably be a crypto
economy right now
no we'd be a gold there would be a gold
back yep yeah no no fed no fed the fed
would have been destroyed you know i
mean no but seriously if you think he's
so wealthy in advance ron paul would be
a cyborg by now he would he'd be a
cyborg he'd be you know he would have
bought cnn and turned it into something
wonderful
be like they would have gained channels
to run a third time but he would have
refused yeah he would have had to have
refused yes i have to be honest though i
obviously wouldn't be a utopia but i do
think it would be a little bit similar
to donald trump
oh yeah no i think so absolutely and the
media would have treated him the way
they treated trump
crazy old yeah he's crazy he's totally
unhinged you know but the people would
have loved him you know and what was
really impressive about ron paul was
his connection with young people and
people who did not traditionally fit
into
the republican mold you know of what the
media wanted you to believe a republican
was and i also felt like that was
another important reason for me to run
was i was like you know i'm tired of
people framing us as this
you know
this tiny box and we all have to fit
inside this cleanly and if we don't then
there's there's just something wrong
with it you know because it's almost
like if you met somebody who looked like
me you would have to expect they're
definitely not a republican and i think
that that's something that needs to
change because the funny part of it is
is like i'm more conservative than your
you know average you could pull anybody
out of the legislature and i'm more
conservative than them and they may look
like they'd fit the part but
if you actually got down to policy and
it was me versus that person making
decisions you're going to be much
happier with the decision i make than
the one they make
you remember the ron paul love
revolution yes it was revolution but
then love flipped around yeah love was
flipped around so it's actually the um
i've only done political ads twice in my
life and the first one i ever did was
for the ron paul campaign and it
included that in it um
yes yes
and we need more of that energy you know
maybe not so much the love at this point
but that'll come later you know but we
need the people to
make some decisions here about what they
want
what i've always liked about ron paul
is that uh you know back then like 2008
and 2009 or whatever i was you know more
lefty but i was like i like this guy
because he comes out and he says a bunch
of things i don't agree with and then he
just says
you know but but i'm not gonna ever have
the government come and tell you what to
do and i'm like then we're good yeah i'm
like i don't care what you believe like
you believe a bunch of things i don't
agree with you on those policies
but then your policy is to leave me
alone yes all right win-win that's the
greatest policy you can run with as a
politician is i want to leave you alone
you know it really is i want to leave
you to do what you want to do within
reason obviously we're not going to let
you go and share you know like child
sexual abuse material or something like
that but you know in general you want to
live your life seems to be the democrat
motto these days it does it's that
democrats would like a world like that
you know where they're able to allow
everything but crypto pedos and pedo
adjacent
you know we we've got to get to a point
where the people really are in control
again and that's not going to happen
unless people like me go ahead and take
the leap and say you know what i'll go
do this and i'm definitely not doing it
for 30 years i think honestly those
people who grow up and they're like i
want to be in congress they're they have
mental problems okay if we're being real
with each other they have mental
problems they're sociopaths and total
narcissists think about how many little
girls today turn on the tv and they see
nancy pelosi
and they're like i want to be that
yep they should probably
be locked up
if they think that when they see nancy
pelosi i'm joking of course but um
they're going to be like
he's they probably will um but no
you know i think that we've got to give
people something to believe in again in
terms of them being able to have the
power again and if the wrong people keep
getting into the positions of power in
this country we're never going to get
there and our kids are going to grow up
in a country that is
incredibly
just inverse from what we want for our
families you know i mean like normal
people want freedom they want they want
to just be able to live a life where you
know their kids get to go to a good
school they have a decent job they get
to go on a date every once in a while
they get to take a vacation with their
kids once a year like people aren't
asking for much and the government in
turn turns around and slaps them all the
time you know and
i think that
we've got to understand
this is probably a good way to frame it
i was asked recently by seb gorka he
said you know you've been around all
these places in your district what is
the common theme and i could give a
political answer but there's there's no
use in it the real answer is pain
there's something about pain and grief
and trauma
that ignites something different in
people
and the pain i'm seeing from people in
their experiences it's not just about
money it's not just about economic
overturn or gas prices or any of these
things it's about a lifetime in many
cases but decades at the very least of
being lied to being slapped at every
turn by your government and
essentially feeling like you run through
the same cycle over and over of abuse
and they're tired they're sick of it
well we got some more abuse coming your
way everybody
in today's segment about the apocalypse
marketwatch.com says inflation has
lessons for a very entitled generation
says blackrock co-founder that's right
one of the largest largest wealth
management firms in the world their
president has come out and said the
entire generation should
what is it what did he say put on their
seat belts to cope with scarcity
inflation saying we've never seen
anything like this for the first time
this generation is going to go into a
store and not be able to get what they
want and we have a very entitled
generation that has never had to
sacrifice he's not completely wrong just
i don't think anybody wants to hear from
this guy wrong messenger and by the way
we did not plan that transition because
that was a perfect transition
it was a little stark but it was perfect
oh yeah the news is coming this is not
the person
that you want delivering this message
this guy is just absolutely i mean these
they're pillagers they're professional
pillagers that's what they do they're
pillaging our communities and they're
making life impossible for young people
we want to know why young people are
turning to socialism and communism it's
because of blackrock blackrock is what
is igniting that because they can't see
a future where they can own a home where
they can have kids credibly and be able
to say oh yeah my kid's gonna have a
good life
democrats it's also democrats because
the democrats policies on like student
loans and all of that yep and all what
ends up happening is you know we want
student loan forgiveness well
inflation hits and everyone's like no i
can't afford to buy a house and so it's
a combination of this it's
corporatocracy and corporate you know
corporate
you know some people said corporate
communism which doesn't really make
there needs to be a new word
so you're touching on the fact that that
this is something that i've noticed a
lot it's hard for us to define what this
is you know because it's sort of a
fusion of a lot of things and we need a
new word because it's really a
technocracy fused with corporatism fused
with left-wing fascism you know so
it's like
it needs its own thing its own
yeah it's chaos you know essentially but
you know i think that
until we stand up to these people it's
not going to end it's saying ism is
toxic technocracy when people are
addictedly using technology that they
don't know how to do no no technocracy
is a rule by through technology
because the people don't have the
ability to repair their stuff and they
don't know how to build the stuff so
it's like this class of builders this
class of industrialists are are now
because they have control of the
production that's why it's a technocracy
otherwise it would be like a
decentralized technological revolution
well they're almost an arm of the
government too though which is another
concerning point because if you look at
the big tech companies they're taking
orders from the democratic party you
look at every one of these tech
companies and i think tim you've
actually talked about this before you
may not remember because you talk so
much about stuff but you talked about um
how many of these big tech companies
have former staffers of the democrat
senators and democrat house members i
mean it's ludicrous it's literally every
single one andy stone from facebook from
facebook from facebook worked for the uh
right it was a democratic congressional
campaign committee yeah i think you work
for barbara boxer too well yeah there
you go and this is a guy who actively
suppressed the hunter biden news story
yep or at least announced they were yep
so these people are evil yep and look
back at the 2020 election they actually
had people uh from california's um
government going and emailing the big
tech companies sending them tweets that
they wanted taken down
okay that is you can't get more blatant
than that the government getting
involved in deleting speech censoring
speech
yeah i used to growing up i was like
well the americans are the good guys so
if we have american technocrats we'll
they'll be they'll do the right thing
but then as i got older i realized no
power just they always it seems to be
corrupt i think power you get insulated
in your own environment people around
you start telling you you're doing good
you're doing the right thing you don't
have to see the fallout from the choices
you're making because you're hidden from
it you're protected and then uh and then
they make utilitarian decisions because
what other choice do you have you got to
be either you make personal decisions
you're utilitarian yeah and you have to
make utilities at least you think you
have to make utilitarian decisions at
that level and you don't see the pain
more of these people in power is never
the answer i mean look at something like
student loans when
did we get an actual student loan
problem when george bush made it
impossible to declare bankruptcy on your
student loans wasn't it it's government
getting involved period
government getting involved period is
the problem government should have never
been involved they shouldn't be in the
loan business they don't know the loan
business they're terrible at it you know
if you look at the actual numbers
they're terrible at it
when there was actually a privatization
of this and you were able to have a bank
go to jenny and say hey jenny
we just don't think it's a good move to
give you 300 000 to get a gender studies
degree
that was a smart sound business decision
and it was honestly a sound decision and
a great favor they were doing to jenny
who wanted to go to gender studies
school for 300 000 or major in it you
know when we got away from that and the
government got involved everything went
downhill or i should say uphill and
we're talking about the prices you know
but that's what happens when government
gets involved it always goes poorly like
they have some value with like fdic
insurance and things like where the
government will insure the loan to the
company if that never gets paid back is
that you think that's valuable
i mean
how rare has it been that it's actually
been something that's been useful to
normal people i just think
people like bill gates
they they look around at uh
he probably watches too many videos
online of just dumb people or he goes to
like reddit uh reddit's the subreddit
idiots in cars and he just sees all this
really awful the worst of humanity and
so then he has this view of just like
yeah you know he's been seeing the worst
since the 80s because he would he was
the technocrat that was watching
everyone's windows activity without them
realizing it for all through the 80s and
the 90s
he created i'm sure he was his company
that's what it's built on is it extracts
data so he's been doing that since he
built it he built in the 80s to a
certain degree he has information on you
know how people use their products and
services
just in general
zuckerberg too is a psychology a
psychologist went to school for
psychology he's not a psychologist he's
a robot he studied it yeah there's just
so many people
that are wealthy that just have disdain
for the working class and regular people
as stupid as 100 percent
the plebeians this is like thousands of
year old and probably even before that
the romans had like an entire class of
pretty much everybody i'm just imagining
normies we're living a story told many
times through history so yeah there are
republicans in your district were uh
sitting
all sitting in their 50 000 a year club
you know drinking uh tea or wine and
smoking cigars and there's just one big
fat republican he's like i dare say this
robbie starbuck who is trying to run we
can't love the rabble in congress
and he's like call up your congressman
your state representative and get a bill
passed you forgot to mention my hair my
hair was definitely a part of that
conversation yeah yeah you just see your
hair it's like oh
it's scared
and then the other guy's like i'll call
them right away
and then you got the accents wrong but
on content probably bad guys are always
british for some reason yeah i think
those are british accents ancient
ancient hatred and see tennessee accents
just sound too nice if you did that same
thing in a tennessee accent it would
sound like a really sweet thing they
were doing but um
no um it's probably pretty similar yeah
i mean that's what happens with power
when you have you know consolidated
power like that among a group of people
they
get very uh protective of each other and
they'll do everything they possibly can
to stop people from shaking that power
up you know look be real though we can't
allow the rabble to be in congress
rabble could you imagine man i think
this is like it's almost scarily
realistic this conversation we're having
because okay it has happened in the past
you had the plebeians and now you have
the 99 and then so is there there must
be a reason that it keeps appearing over
and over again maybe it's by design
maybe a small group of 120 iq people
decided to orchestrate society so that
they could stay on top or maybe we just
have not learned the lesson yet you know
there's that meme what does it go like
hard times create um strong strong men
strong strong men create hard times
strongly make good times good times yeah
good times great week man weak men
create hard times and it goes on
there's a lot of truth to that that's
what it is man and that's what we're
living through there's been a lot of
very very weak men for a long time who
have gotten very comfortable
sitting around with their cigars
drinking whatever they drink they have
no clue what the heck their kids are
doing their kids turn into far left
crazy people and they're totally
disconnected from reality for normal
people
and then you build a society where times
get really hard which i would actually
argue we're entering into right now i
think people are going to really start
to feel the effects of
what these people have done to our world
over the past couple of decades and
2026. we're going to have some very
strong men rise out of it that are going
to have to bring us out and aren't going
to have to do hard things
2026 so many people have told me that's
that's the year and i'm like what does
that mean that surprises me well it's uh
there's a couple different you know
analyses there's mit's data on you know
they calculated 40 years ago when it was
all gonna hit the fan there's some other
guy who gave an interview device like 10
years ago as an expert on the stuff said
it's all gonna hit the fan in the early
2020s and then you have strass out
generational theory which predicts we're
entering the final season of tumult and
but however
did they include joe biden in their
calculations
because it may be coming sooner
pre-civil war buchanan yeah we we had a
feckless pathetic president then and
many people have said joe biden seems to
be our buchanan which is going to lead
us into this this this tumultuous period
look if donald trump wins in 2024 do you
think the left is going to be like well
you know donald trump won fair and
square so let's
no definitely nope oh my gosh that'd be
great absolutely not yeah and the civil
war that we're headed towards now is
going to be like the metaverse versus
base reality and like yeah well that's
not for sub humans
we've got a little time before we get
there i think we're going to have an
actual physical experience that people
are going to live through something
that they're going to say this used to
be things we only read about and this is
reality now and i'd say this has been a
long-term problem for our country that
our young people have been largely
disconnected from the experiences of the
world and it's a picture on a screen not
a reality not a physical thing that you
can understand and so if they see the
experiences of somebody in let's say
africa
it's just a photo it's just an image you
can't feel it you can't taste it you
can't touch it you don't know what that
world is actually like and i think when
they go through the hard times that we
may be facing unless some really drastic
things happen
it's gonna it's gonna change things it's
gonna change everything and even down to
relationship levels of what people want
out of their partners and what people
want out of their life in general and
you're going to see so much change it's
going to make this great migration look
like nothing this thing that's happened
where everybody's moved all over the
country it's going to make that look
like nothing because you're going to see
changes that are just flipped on their
head in every segment of society i think
our audience deserves some good news and
so i will be fair and we're going to do
a feel-good story and this story is
federal election commission finds dnc
and clinton over russia gate hoax
uh yes refreshing your feel-good story
of the evening uh hillary clinton only
got fined i think a a small amount of
money but uh let's read according to a
scoop from paul bedard of the washington
examiner the election agency said that
clinton and dnc violated strict rules
and describing expenditures of payments
funneled to the opposition research firm
fusion gps through their law firm a
combined 1 million 24
407.97 was paid by the treasurers of the
dnc and the clinton campaign to to law
firm perkins coe for fusion gps's
information and the party and campaign
hid the reason claiming it was for legal
services not opposition research instead
the dnc's 849 thousand four hundred
seven dollars and 97 cents and the
clinton campaign's 175 000
covered fusion gps's opposition research
on the dossier a basis for the so-called
russia hoax that dogged trump's first
term
so i believe we have the numbers here
the report says the agency fined
clinton's treasurer eight thousand
dollars in the dnc 105 000
so um
it could be good news but i could i do
kind of feel like a lot of people are
going to see that and say it's it's
sweeping under the road well there's
more news too the federal election
commission was just found dead
uh yes i'm just kidding it's the
entirety of the organization just gone
overnight the organization died
mysteriously in its sleep no you know
what i love about the hillary clinton
meme is that it like regular people used
it yeah like normies talking about video
games 100 like a video game company goes
out of business and then the fake tweet
appears
like
it's just funny it's fun no but i think
i mean this is
i have trouble getting excited about
things like this to be perfectly honest
with you because it feels like
the carrot they dangle in front of you
you know and i'm tired of having carrots
dangled in front of people and i think
people are tired of it they just want
the damn carrot they don't want a nibble
of it they don't want to keep seeing it
waved in front of them they want the
whole carrot they know what's going on
and that's the thing is for so long
we've had it just yeah and it's almost
insulting honestly eight grand like come
on hillary clinton doesn't care about
eight grand that's that's the other
insulting part of it so i just i kind of
find it insulting more so than good news
i mean
it could be the precursor to something i
mean uh donald trump is suing
the dnc suing clinton or the dc he's
suing a whole bunch of democrats over
the russia gate hoaxes this obviously
will play very well into his lawsuit
yeah no this will help him for sure
but where do we where where do we go
from here if there is no accountability
for people like this who are still
running and as we talked about in the
previous segment trying to stop you from
being able to go into congress
i mean i think we're gonna see that
decline only speed up if if there
continues to be no consequences and they
continue to be able to sort of build
this machine that keeps out outsiders
then it's just gonna get worse faster
you know whereas i feel like if we get
this right in 2022 and this is probably
the best chance we've got because people
are so angry right now
um at least in this time period i mean
you can argue a lot of things maybe in
2026 20 30 may happen that may make
people take a different route but in in
this election i feel like we do have a
great opportunity there are strong
people and not just in congress i'm
talking locally i mean what did we learn
from kovid who you elect locally
matters more than who you elect for
president in so many cases yep you know
that's that's what changed your life
during covet was who your mayor was who
your you know local sheriff was and all
that so people need to show up and the
other lesson for all of this though is
show up to primaries and local elections
they're more important than the general
even i i would argue that because
we need to pick the very best people for
all of these positions what what what's
your uh your district is
district five yeah it's a republican
district you know you know the cook pvi
is i think it's plus 12 now in the new
district yeah wow so it was actually
plus 17 at one point democrat um and it
had been in democracy for over 100 years
but it was redistricted this year
because the population growth in middle
tennessee over the past decade has been
massive just exploded and it's largely
the exodus of conservatives out of
california new york and illinois oh
coming in coming in well daily wire yep
they've brought all our employees
there's a bunch of companies coming in
you know i mean just left and right
companies because we're a very business
friendly state you know we're one of
those states with a zero percent state
tax too when you come here so it's just
very friendly and enticing this means
that the primary is the actual election
yes because whoever wins the primary is
going to win
basically no matter what yep so you need
to make sure all of you listening that
you go out and vote in your primaries
and your local elections
enough states uh we're really close to a
constitutional convention very close
that means if people all go out if every
single person who listened to this show
went and told all their immediate
friends hey we're going to go vote in
the in the in the local elections yes
i'm pretty sure republicans would win
these states well and consider this too
okay so this is the other thing we have
to think tactically so if you're looking
at elections right now and you say you
know what in my district it doesn't
really matter we're very safe we've got
a good person or there's no way you're
getting this person whatever it is okay
you can make a difference in other parts
of the country you can phone bank for
other parts of the country find races
that matter where it does matter like
you say i have to get that person in you
know there may be some guy on like a
podcast you really like you know like
with a cool name like robbie and you're
like hey i want to make sure that guy
gets elected go and actually do
something to that effect you know you
don't even have to live there you can do
it these are federal races but then in
the local side of things make sure
you're involved make sure you know who
your mayor is you know where they stand
on things because that's been the shock
for a lot of people they've found their
mayors are little tyrants who want to
control their lives let's make sure we
don't do that anymore let's elect people
who actually want the people to be free
what do you think you're gonna be
hanging out with uh so when you get
elected you mean hanging out with like
uh marjory taylor green and thomas
massey and the freedom caucus people
absolutely cause that's what we need
more of yes i hear that i heard more
more stories from them the thing about
marjory was that she came on the show
she's been on the show i think twice now
and um
a lot of people messaged me saying we
only heard crazy things about her we
never really really looked into it but
then when she told the story about how
she forced members of congress to do an
actual vote on bills yeah
i'm getting all these messages from
people cheering being like wow she had
the backbone to risk a lot of things i
can't like fully go into but she risked
a lot of things to support me and i will
always
always appreciate that and like i said
politics is a business where they want
you to stab your friends in the back and
i refuse to do it i will never ever ever
do that or you know talk down about
somebody who's been an incredible friend
or supporter and she's
she cares she cares about this country
she cares about freedom she cares about
people like and i think that's one of
the things that people would be
surprised by is even if you disagreed
with her if you just sat down and talked
with her she cares about our country she
cares about people and she doesn't want
anybody hurting you know but this was
this was an amazing thing for us to
learn uh thanks to the freedom caucus uh
and many of these other people is that
members of congress don't actually vote
on these bills yeah they just have
proxies and like there's banging a gavel
and just shuffling it through like yes
you know whatever who cares it's almost
like there's no congress this point i
mean look nancy pelosi pushes through
her her spending bill nobody has a
chance to read it
whoever's speaker of the house is
it was supposed to be at least according
to ben franklin the way he was
envisioning it was that it would be like
a jury duty summons you'd get a summons
to go serve on congress for a while and
then when you're done you go home but
people couldn't afford it well you know
part of why congress is so broken is
it's the fundraising side of things we
have a bunch of people who are good
fundraisers and they're terrible
representatives a bunch of people to
that effect and that's the reality of it
you know if you don't if you're not
either independently wealthy or you
can't fundraise like crazy and you're
just a really good person with great
ideas that can get things done like
you're not you're not winning your race
you have got to be able to spend money
in these races and that's what's
terrible is that it's created this sort
of system where
you have a bunch of people who
if corporations will come to you and say
like amazon or big farmer whoever it is
and they say hey we'll give you x amount
and we'll throw all this money into
packs that are going to support you
these people take the money yeah and
then it is a quid pro quo and nobody
will admit it but i'm i'm admitting it
you know it is that's 100 what these
people are doing and it's why i refuse
to take their money because we need to
be able to stand put a line in the sand
and say
this whole thing that's been going on
this is what is ruining our country
nobody's going in there to vote or to
reading or to writing or legislating in
any part any segment of it and saying
hey
how's this going to affect like your
average family in the middle of the
country
what i don't get is how why does it cost
money because i started i made a youtube
channel in 2006. i was like wow i've got
10 000 subscribers pretty quick i don't
need money to run for office now i have
what money buys which is the platform to
speak
so what do you need money for example so
i have a large platform and that's what
a lot of people ask me is they're like
well why would i need to donate to you
have like almost a million followers via
all your social media like why would you
need me millions of people watch you
blah blah blah they don't live in my
district you know maybe 24 of my
district consumes their content online
the rest of them either it's like still
newspapers they listen to radio or their
tv or they just they don't do any of
that and they're people who work they
work for a living they go home they
spend time with their family that's it
they're pretty disconnected from what's
going on in the news
you have to be able to send out mailers
you have to be able to make sure your
name's out there and especially in
primaries the number one predictor of
primary who's going to win is name id so
if you actually do a poll on just name
id do have you heard this name before
that person's much more likely to win if
their higher end name id whether it's
good bad indifferent doesn't matter they
just know the name people are going to
be like starbuck that sounds familiar
you get my vote yeah well you know
that's that's part of the hope but no
you've got to be able to get this stuff
out there and actually make people feel
something about you you know and that's
that's a good thing whether it's good or
bad because you've got to stand in what
you actually are going to do you know
and in my case it's a good thing because
i'm in a conservative district but
you've got to pay for the ads that's the
other thing is that
ads are one of the critical ways you
know if there's another let's say
28 of people who watch everything that
they get about politics on tv if you're
not present in those ads you're not
there in their ad space in that time
they're spending watching tv but your
opponent is
you're in trouble you know and i've seen
that in a lot of races where there's an
incredible person but they raised just
not enough money to be able to do ads
outside of maybe one or two places and
their opponent has money from you know
all these corporate super pacs and they
can just
flood the zone flooding the zone is the
name of the game they know how to flood
the zone in these places where people
consume this content the person becomes
more familiar with the name and maybe
their only familiarity with your name
now is that corporate pack who ran
negative ads against you saying this
person you know um
they they hate trump watch this video
where they hated trump and it'll be like
a video of this person doing that but in
reality the truth of it is it was a
video of that person playing a part
during a party game where they're
explaining what you do during voting you
know and they just took it entirely out
of context but the people watching it
will never know that you know
that's something you've got to sort of
be able to to battle you know and if you
don't have the money to do it then
people are going to have the wrong
impression about you so like in my case
the thing they're going to go after say
he's to hollywood he's directed you know
all these people who are hollywood
values and blah blah blah
you know how do you know he's really
gonna fight for you and it's like
what have you done
what have you done and if you can't
fight back or credibly like give people
an argument for why they should vote for
you then they're just gonna move on you
know and do what feels comfortable i
love getting these text messages i just
pulled one up from this uh this past
week
uh this is somebody running against
lauren bobert
and that's basically their pitch
that that's that's that's it i don't
like we don't like her and uh give us
money maybe not that it's maybe not
illegal the right way but running smear
ads
what how how can you justify taking
political money and then running an ad
to to make someone else look bad what
does that do with your political that is
all they're going to do in my race
against me because i have higher name id
than basically everybody in the field
and so the problem with that for them is
they want to make sure that's attached
to something negative so for them that's
hollywood they feel like the hollywood
thing is going to really hurt see
my whole thought on that is actually
pretty far out from where they're at i
think because i'm like this is what they
try to do to trump people don't believe
this crap anymore yeah you know like
i directed something that had a violence
in it or something like that it's like
yeah that was my job this is not reality
it was not reality it was part of my job
people care about where you're at on
policy you know yeah they'll they'll see
that commercial was like and robbie
starbuck something something something
it's all black and white and then it
shows the other guy with like the
sunshine is like and this guy does the
thing well they'll probably they'll
search your name and they'll see you
talking on this show and something like
that yeah this is the guy yes that's the
real person it's good marketing you know
so and it depends do they care enough to
do that you know that's the real
question do enough people care enough to
do that to make that search to take that
leap and say am i being lied to i think
people are becoming more awake to that
and the necessity of doing things like
that but you know the reality is is that
you've got to meet people where they are
and that's the big part of fundraising
is that and so you know you're at a
handicap if you say i'm just going to
refuse all the corporate money but i
think it's critical to the direction
we're going as a country
you've got to take that stand and a
bunch of members criticized me early on
they were like dude i get it i want to
do the same thing but you've got to just
do this so you win
and i'm like i would rather sell my
house
dead serious for my kids i would rather
sell my house than take money from
amazon
because that is just the beginning of
you compromising values we'll clarify
too i mean when you say take money
typically it's like they dump it into a
super pack and then adds on your behalf
yeah tip you know usually they're like
the you know the super pac and the
candidate don't coordinate but they do
it's bs and then so if like amazon put
however much what would be their maximum
amount that amazon could put into a
campaign for someone could yeah
okay so in a pack it's unlimited and
then what if you're just like thanks you
run the campaign you win and then you're
like yeah bye amazon i'm not involved
anymore thanks for helping me like now
i'm going to do what i what i want to do
i've never seen anybody do it what
typically happens when you're
running an illegal uh uh bribery scheme
and then you uh uh don't give the guys
who bribed you what they've asked for
they come crook and the knuckles
well no that's exactly it is like okay
go off the premise of how this all works
if you really made a back room deal with
some company that you're going to do
their bidding and do what they want and
they dump in millions into your pack to
make sure you can go do that do you
really think that they won't go out and
expose you in some way because the
company is going to get a slap on the
wrist but you
you'll get in real trouble you're an
individual it's supposed to be a it's a
donation those are donations right
they're making donations which have no
quid pro quo attached to them well and
there's a lot of rules with the pacs so
like you know you're not supposed to
communicate or anything like that with
them you know as a candidate i can't
talk to a pack i don't even have a pack
but if i did have a pack you know let's
say further closer to the election i
can't communicate in any way with them
there's ways you're allowed to go speak
at events and things like that but it's
a very serious rule you can't you know
you're not supposed to at least but the
good people follow the rules and the
vast majority don't follow those rules i
don't think that i think there's like
three or maybe like five good people
yeah most people may be well intentioned
when they get in but then like you said
they're like look look it's corrupted
one thing you got to do you've got to do
it yep that's the first compromise is
the last compromise because the minute
you start doing it it will never stop
and it'll just keep going you just know
that when he got in office they sat him
down the intelligence agencies and they
were like this is the plan and the
mission is what we're doing he went no
excuse me we're getting our troops out
it's not happening and and they got
positive that's why i love the guy
that's why i love the guy you know
people this is what's funny is after he
endorsed um the other candidate in this
race and everybody was like you got to
be so mad all these these news outlets
come nbc cnn all these places like do
you want to come obviously they want me
to go in and bash him you know they're
like we've got division in the maga
movement candace owens went against what
trump said marjorie taylor green went
against what he said his own lawyers
went against it and goes on and on and
on and you know i was like this is
everything you guys want no i'm not
going to do it i love the guy like he's
hilarious this is the energy we need
people who are outsiders who are going
to fight this insane system they're
going to make mistakes along the way
they're not always going to be perfect
but they're going to do their damn best
to do what people need it feels like a
plane that's going down and we need a
pilot to help us crash land because the
federal reserve had this it's been going
on for 100 years they've been printing
and printing and printing to a point
where we can't we owe more interest than
we can pay back now and they're using
this global catastrophe as like the
covet shutdown as an excuse to reset it
yeah as an excuse but it was headed like
a great reset a big really big a really
big one you'd call it almost like a
gargantuan reset
um
i i just don't know how to i hope
someone can crash land it properly we do
need people with high energy that at
least what we need is like a a
a shared vision of reality yes yes this
is something that is critical okay
critical to the future of our country we
have so many mixed realities right now
and one of the most unifying things for
a society is your fundamental ability to
agree on what reality is even language
like look at language in our country we
can't even agree on words right now well
we can but they're people who are lying
yeah but exactly but then they're
confusing people who are growing up in
this environment and those people who
are growing up confused you know i don't
blame them i blame the evil people who
are doing this
but what they're producing and what
they're trying to do is create the
elements necessary to bring full bore
communism that's that's my deepest
belief you know my family already fled
communism once everything they're doing
now is not new this is something that's
been done many times before and it was
done in cuba where my family had to flee
you know
this is not a new thing we just need to
wake up and stop it before it comes to
reality and destroys the future of our
country you know this is decision time
and we have a lot of people who have
decision fatigue in our country where
they're just they're tired they're tired
of making decisions but this is the time
where people need to be strong and say
you know what we've got to make those
right decisions we've got to we've got
to do things and make sacrifices now
because if we don't we're going gonna
end up in a situation where we're gonna
have to make some really really serious
sacrifices
and that's the truth of it so if people
wake up enough and they say i can make
this small sacrifice now great
if they don't though i think we're gonna
end up in a situation where they're
gonna be forced into serious sacrifice
so you want people to just put forth
that extra burst of energy like when
you're near the end of a race when you
just can't run anymore in everything not
just not just with me you know not just
like oh go donate to my campaign at
starbucks22.com not just that okay but
like actual energy and everyday life
about living your values you know like
this disney thing i think we're probably
going to talk about right the disney
thing
don't go take your kid to disneyland
it's not going to ruin their life don't
give disney more money don't give money
to people who hate well there are a lot
of traffickers that are getting arrested
at disney over the past several years i
don't know i i probably wouldn't want to
go there anyway don't go there don't
give them your money show some strength
have a spine cancel your netflix account
all these companies who hate you stop
giving them your money see i i have no
netflix um but people here do have
netflix so it's like it's on anyway uh i
when disney plus came out i bought a
year because i just it's always cheaper
just to buy the year forward and then
what happened was was the the uyghur
muslim thing and i was like so i'm not
gonna be renewing it that's for sure
yeah and i just i just it's all around
not that good when we start demanding
that our values are actually able to be
lived out in everything things will
change but my point that i'm trying to
get to is the answer isn't in my opinion
to tell everybody to cancel their
netflix i see some people are mentioning
they did
obviously you want to cancel your
netflix but the real answer is daily
wire needs to ramp up yes absolutely we
need to start producing more cultural
content uh people who are
anti-establishment it's not just about
conservative it's about your
anti-establishment your populist your
libertarian these are the values that
most of us share
i tried uh i wanted to watch hyperions i
wanted to watch the new daily wire movie
but i can't watch it on my tv
because you've got daily wear on like
roke or whatever but i have a smart tv
yeah that means daily wire needs to make
an lg app guys what are you doing and i
i i think i don't know if they have the
sony app but our sony tv is android bay
so i think we can download download
download the android it's a good word
download dude i'm gonna have to check
because i checked about three or four
months ago and i couldn't do it on a
sony tv but um you know hopefully they
have because i think that you are
absolutely right it's an android this is
a critical critical next step
we've got to you know fill these holes
in culture in every way you know school
choice is another example of this you
know i know it's a far leap for a lot of
people from talking about entertainment
but these are cultural pillars
and think about how different our
country is going to look if you told
parents you're like let's take a place
like baltimore okay they take uh about
17 500 per child they earmark for them
to go to public school
meanwhile they're producing
kids one out of 10 graduate high school
in baltimore proficient in math and
reading okay
that's not something that should ever
happen in america now imagine you take
that 17 500 you hand it to parents and
you say do what you want to educate your
child it is up to you your job you
handle it no strings attached from
government government is not going to
get in the way of this do what you want
imagine 20 of them decide to homeschool
and now you have 20 more kids in our
country staying at home with a parent
for those formative years
what kind of cultural effects are there
going to be long term it's going to be
massive everything you can think of from
incarceration rates to you know um the
jobs that people choose you know
family how long people stay together
everything will change everything will
change in society based off just these
small things that will change from
school choice and if you fill those gaps
give people choice and this is another
one you know daily wire it's truly about
not just getting conservative content
out there it's about giving people a
real choice right now we live in a
system in the entertainment industry and
everywhere else where we don't really
have real choices it's basically you
have 10 options of the same left-wing
garbage and that's it you know i want to
know that's why i started making my own
music too i want to shout out this meme
i posted on twitter so somebody somebody
posted uh well so let's start with james
lindsey he said this is art slippery
slope fallacy you're overreacting you're
overreacting and then it's like you know
disney employees
and then i responded quote so what if
government employees want to have sexual
conversations
with your four-year-old in secret
and then someone posted this meme when
you tell the democrat they can't teach
sex to kindergartners and it's the
arthur making a fist where they're
getting mad well i fixed it i put when
you tell a democrat they can't have
sexual conversations with four-year-olds
in secret because that's what's going on
in florida which has resulted in all of
this that's what democrats want
it's and and i'm i'm i'm not going to
mince words because i'm just
anybody
who who knowingly opposes the parental
rights and education bill is saying why
can't we have secret conversations with
four to nine year olds about sexual
topics it's a pedophile agenda it's it's
it's complete groomer it's pedophile
adjacent at the very least but there's a
lot of crypto pedos you know what does
that mean no it's a pedophile agenda
cryptically so so uh
pedo means they're people who are
playing with kids yeah this is this is
one of those stages of going into
communism because first of all it fits a
couple different categories separating
children from their parents okay
communists love to do that they like to
separate kids from their parents because
fundamentally they need to take over a
parental role they need that child to
see them as a parent and that's what
bills like this do is push us closer and
not the bill but the action that they
want and why they're so mad about the
bill is they want to be able to push
those kids closer to the state being
mommy or daddy okay
and
if they can't talk to them about these
critical issues that are supposed to be
things that parents talk to their kids
about and teach their kids about
you know that's a problem for them
because that's that's getting in the way
of their agenda now beyond just that
this is just step one the next step in
this is if they feel like they can move
the overton window far enough over where
suddenly you get 50 of democrats or 60
or 70 or 80 okay with this idea that yes
in fact the state does have a right to
have a sexual conversation with a
four-year-old and share their own
sexuality and sex life with their
four-year-old if that becomes normalized
what's next it's going to be a child
sexual rights agenda and that's what
people need to be woke to is that's
what's coming down the line next and if
you're not aware of it now and you don't
fight this and you don't do what you can
to stop this now
then
you're just okay with that next step you
know i gotta be honest uh if you go back
in time
there was talk about the slippery slope
and it all happened and now here we are
10 years later and once again we're
having same conversations it's going to
get bad and
i hope i i hope that at least the
reality of knowing that there's been
some things that were correct about that
is going to wake people up enough to say
oh maybe there's something we need to do
differently here yeah big time knowing
what the system is doing yeah
drastically changes the system itself
yeah the calculus has changed you know
and i think that's something that we all
need to take really seriously i mean
that's what my wife does is you know she
works in this area she's actually
launching a non-profit to do exactly
this stop child exploitation because
we've essentially created a pipeline for
kids from birth to exploit them you know
look at social media how early kids are
on tick tock or how early they're on
instagram pages with absolutely no
oversight and we teach girls
specifically that like commodifying
yourself making yourself into a
commodity and it's your body essentially
is a good thing that's the stuff broken
societies do dude i was just thinking
about little kids seeing pornography on
the internet like when they're two three
and four you know what the average age
is
my guess is four what is it the average
age in america right now where
somebody's exposed to hardcore porn so
like a video is 11. that's 11 years old
that's documented yeah because kids
might see it not even know they're
seeing it when they're three that's
that's the average yeah they wouldn't be
able to answer the question when they do
those things where they try to figure
this out they wouldn't even be able to
answer three or four so if you just said
you know
that probably likely happens to a
certain extent you would probably say
that number in reality is a little bit
lower but that's the one that's
documented is that it's at least 11. it
shouldn't be that way you know and this
is not we're not talking about like them
sneaking under their grandpa's you know
mattress and getting a play this is
really graphic stuff yeah this is this
is horrific stuff that they're seeing
it's the first time in human history
that i know of that humans have been
exposed to this kind of content at that
age and i'm wondering if the people that
are in their 20s now are the people that
saw that stuff when they were four yeah
in 2003 when internet video appeared
yeah and that's and now they're teaching
now they're teachers well i have i have
somewhat of a controversial take too
when it comes to porn and it's that you
know i feel like we as men have a
responsibility to normalize
the fact that you should feel
emasculated if you have to watch porn i
feel like we should try to normalize
normal sexual healthy relationships with
your spouse
and that you know porn in itself is not
doing anything positive for you like if
you look at things from a net positive
or net life drain basis it's draining
things from your life and nothing it's
producing is really good for you you
know just like we were saying profane
things aren't necessarily the f word you
can be profane i think you can be
pornographic without sex and not all sex
is pornographic there's way it's just
you know it's the way that it's
portrayed i'm not sure i fully
understand yeah
i think i think you were wrong about
that i watch a lot of that
you could say there's some that's like
healthy sex people enjoying themselves
and they're somewhere i suppose if
you're watching like uh educational
science you know thing that's like very
dry and and you know just like an old
man is going as the man becomes but who
who needs that though like honestly you
know if you're like a med school
you know or you're a biologist i'm sorry
if you're a biologist or you're in med
school and you need to see that video
you should probably pick it up you're
completely wrong i'm talking about an
educational thing showing like organs
like okay that that that's okay i
thought you meant like a play-by-play on
how sex works because that was going to
be like your parents
all the chemical functions you could you
could they could make a video showing to
people having sex it wouldn't be porn
yeah it would be like a medical
biological thing we gotta go to super
chat so if you haven't already smash the
like button subscribe to this channel
share the show with your friends and
make sure you become a member over at
timcast.com we're gonna have a members
only segment coming up around 11 p.m i
just want to point out some people are
saying we already got censored for
talking about um
florida and those democrats and the
things that they are doing so uh
maybe people are saying the feed cut out
we started talking about some spicy
stuff that's why we have timcast.com but
let's read some of these super chats
let's see we got
what is this one
mikhail isaacson says swedish companies
atlas copco sandvik and skf questioned
about selling parts to russia for
building nukes according to newspaper
expresson as i've said many times before
sweden is the final puppet master hmm
interesting
very important super [ __ ] here from
brian page he says
let's go brandon let's go interesting
that's my favorite super chat
interesting yeah so far at least so far
okay you're in first place for now
woot do for you says i just want to know
what's happened to women last three i
dated all were closet addicts and had
some form of personality disorder a
misaffected liberal seems like christian
women are the only option
uh i think in cities there's uh uh
for one women are mass medicated in this
country with birth control which is a
hor which is which is hormonal which
does cause
you know psychological effects on any
individual who takes you know hormones
and uh as for people living in cities
you know the first thing i'll say is bro
if everywhere you walk it smells like
crap you got to check your boot maybe
it's you but it's also possible that in
cities especially over the past two
years people become dejected depressed
and purposeless and so they do drugs
and they develop personality disorders
from it
look at the average life of a girl in
our country like if you just did like
you tried to do a replay like a
30-second cut of life for a girl and
what they're expected
to do now and what matters to a woman
you know it's supposed to matter and i
think it's fundamentally changed from
what it's been for a very long time in
history and i think that it's led to
really unhealthy outcomes yeah i saw the
article saying that they found
microplastics in the human blood for the
first time and they're as they're
researching it they're fine that it
appears in babies way more because the
blood-brain barrier is much more
permeable and i wonder if little
children if somehow women are more
impacted by like the chemicals in the
system look at diet too diet this is the
first time in human history that we've
really eaten processed foods all the
time
all the time our diets entirely changed
from what it was for hundreds and
hundreds of years thousands of years
what kind of
so processed food also includes like
you know pepperoni and and i'm talking
about like processes
you know like like if we're going into
like super yeah i mean just think about
the diet your average person has you
know like if you're eating fast food on
a regular basis you're doing all this
stuff and you're not getting food from
the earth and you're not you know sort
of
having somewhat of
a mindset that you care about what you
put in your body this is very different
from history because in history we were
fundamentally getting our food from the
ground from animals period you know
there wasn't really other options we
weren't creating it in a factory
somewhere and then eating cheetos you
know that does have an effect on our
health long term and our outcomes you
know and even just you know if you go
into brain science it has an effect on
your brain you know so
i think that there's a lot of different
factors that have changed for humanity
and you touched on all of the
you know psychotropics that people are
on you know there's tons of medicines
that people are on that we've never been
on before and we guess it really what
the outcomes and changes are going to be
or what we pass on to our kids you know
so i think
you got to consider all that all right
we got jay shartzer who says glad to see
you back ian out of all the graphene
hippie jesus look-alikes you are number
one that's just how you roll and murph
says glad to see you back ian now roll
the bones all right i'm rolling the one
that has all 20s on it though
well
why i want to see what i get
i got a 20. oh wow i'll roll the real
one guys you got a two and a zero
rolling the 20 was actually rolling a
one you're right it's a i rolled an
eight that's the infinity symbol i'm
into it all right all right i'll give
you that one straight eight
all right uh
omega says ian will have a twenty two uh
a 20 20 and still managed to roll a one
you weren't right i thought it'd be
funny actually if you roll the 20 and
then it landed straight up pointing on
one of the tips and just doesn't
give you anything that would be great
you know in my life you guys i've rolled
a lot of ones but i just keep going and
then you start rolling 20s again and
then you'll be like i'm rolling twenties
lauren says with daily wires
announcement today i want to shout out
other crater projects like lotus eaters
and your own tim cast who are creating
news and culture platforms to break the
grip of nonce disney
so uh what are daily wire announcements
they're doing uh children's content yes
that's a big announcement there was a
board meeting i saw jeremy boring
fantastic or like a a speech he was
giving on i mean there's there's big
money in kids
and they're expanding the razer company
they're actually creating the razer
company because they have a the razer
product but no company yet so that's
what they're in the process there's a
market for all this stuff you know like
my family with three kids 13 85 we're
not giving any money to disney period
they create a kid's company and it's
content that you actually can feel
comfortable letting your kids consume
they've got customers the only way to
really win in the in in the cultural
battle is to make culture and for the
past 10 years in the culture war the
anti-establishment anti-woke has been
complaining about culture not getting
jobs these companies not pushing back
while i was being infiltrated and
destroyed and rebuilt
so now
hopefully not too little too late but
still a bit late a lot of companies are
starting to say we're going to produce
cultural content and you know good for
them all it takes is one blowing up when
one blows up
there's going to be a lot more i think i
think the daily wire is going to grow
much faster than people realize i think
so too you know they're just getting
started i think they have what three in
four movies yep and they're in my
district they're in my district too so
i'm a big big extra big fan of daily
wire because i feel like they're gonna
bring a lot of jobs to our area so i'm
excited for them we might we might be
down there in a week yeah yeah we're
gonna head over to i told you you could
come over and shoot yeah we'll come over
and shoot at my farm it'll be fun oh
that sounds cool yeah how big is the
farm 12 acres yeah that's good yeah
all right let's see matthew ratcamp says
would you be willing to debate mark
levin him on your podcast or you on his
radio show on the proposed assassination
of putin why he is is he pro-putin
assassination
i think so i think
yes um
you know you know the the one issue is i
mean i'd love to have him on this show
for sure that'd be awesome we could talk
about whatever you know
all right let's see we got here that
would be a riot nitro cat says robbie
starbuck i loved your work on asking
alexandria a prophecy oh cool that video
has a ton of views on youtube i think
it's like 150 million or something whoa
really yeah you got to help us put
together some music videos yeah thank
you we've got a bunch coming out with
our will of the people stuff so uh
the two that we've been working on which
are all part of this universe
which we launched i've retired from
music videos but i would come out of
retirement to do yours i would do that
right
you and smashing pumpkins i told billy a
long time ago i'll come out and i'll do
another pumpkins video if you guys ask
me but that's it yo can we get billy to
collab but you got his you know he
absolutely should he 100 should i'll
send him your song too i figured you
guys knew each other well we've met yeah
and it was like one of the coolest
moments of my life because he told me he
was a fan and he is he is rad he's so
people always ask me what's the coolest
celebrity you've ever worked with and it
is not even a question it's a thousand
percent billy corgan because i was the
hugest smashing pumpkin fan and i
directed a a video um and in that time
it was my birthday and he gave me a
private concert for my birthday just him
at a piano in this wrestling arena place
we were at and he sat there and played
all my favorite songs for me and my crew
and that was it and it was the coolest
thing ever such a rad moment getting to
meet uh billy corbin's i was uh such a
big fan of smashing pumpkins uh for for
obvious reasons you know such a huge
band so that was cool man it would be
awesome i mean we got pete pirata
formerly of the offspring yeah yeah
comes first so good he's awesome and
he's amazing i like him the drum track
he did we got two songs one's called
pain once called bright eyes or bright
eyed
srd but uh when he did he he did this
amazing drum thing where he did like
three separate drum tracks
for uh the song pain yeah which is just
cool and he's like he's banging on a tom
standing up while he's playing it's
legit it's cool stuff yeah all right
let's uh let's grab some more super
chats we got austin walters says glad tn
uh tennessee five was redistricted we're
now in your district joe should start a
comedy and podcasting streaming service
so if you're in my district you better
go to my website and
donate and then volunteer and request a
sign because we need yard signs in your
yard
all right let's see we got
rob matt says hire joe rogan you can pay
him in dmt but don't
mr physics says hey gang just wanted to
let you know you inspired me to start a
3d printing company and as a thank you
i'm going to make a spherical die for
each of you
makers 3d prints on etsy cool man really
appreciate that that's great epic
the fact that you started a company epic
dude
all right
catherine halliday says so now we have
will smith alec baldwin and juicy does
anyone see a trend here as someone from
scotland i miss sheamus but glad ian is
back i'm a sheamus too sheamus uh uh you
know can you believe the nerve of this
guy he just thinks that his freedom
tunes is more important than tim
castillo he's got like he's got freedom
in the name of his
product or something how dare he he not
be on this show
all right all right
what is this uh murph says tim when are
we gonna get the timcast.com eight-hour
special debate on of ian and sheamus on
religion
as soon as ian and chambers do it dude
i'm gonna hit up michael knowles when
we're down there and maybe we can all do
something with the d-dubs that would be
those guys they got a lot of info and
knowledge i like uh jeremy's got a lot
of info i think we see a pastor boring
at some point jiren
did someone said that i don't know
i don't think so no it could be apparent
doesn't sound right
look it up yeah that doesn't sound like
something that that could be true he
just called himself a god king so yeah
i'm going to vote no on was a pastor
previously yeah he a christian pastor he
was established a home church in los
angeles are you serious yeah he was
that's something i did not know wow that
is new information i apologize i was
wrong you sly animal did you guys hear
their his song uh uh him and smokey
smokey mike in the god kingdom yeah it's
a good song oh really you know so he's
here on the show and he's like look it's
a joke he's like i play i'm not that
good and then you play the song
it's a really good song
it is funny it is hilarious what they
did smokey mike in the god king but ian
you should play you'd love it oh great
yeah
there's some other people on our side
who have very
really really impressive musical talent
i'm excited to get it going man
hopefully there will be we can disperse
the sides and just make the best music
as a species yes this is of course why
you know so many people want to rip off
my
music talent but uh what can be said uh
uh but we did talk about that all right
let's see we got here
the great anywho says well texas just
presented a bill
hb4122 also called the don't say
graphene bill sorry ian love you bro
glad you're back
what
that's got to be a lie yeah they were
they were apparently they were debating
over uh whether or not ian says graphene
too much on tim cast irl and so they
passed let's end right now yes the
answer is yes too much
but now you know what graphene is don't
you okay here we go dave says watched
will of the people and then the knockoff
version tim cast's version is
unquestionably better and i can't wait
to see the content that comes out of it
bring on the movie yeah because we were
talking about a movie of this of this
universe and it's just it's
sociopolitical themes and stuff but we
have a couple songs will of the people
the song is kind of like the overarching
universe of this country in in in this
tumult and then the other songs are like
singular moments within it so one of the
things we're planning on doing is that
in the animations because we're using
the same animation the same style color
schemes and all that stuff in the next
songs
they're going to be from key moments
that will reflect back upon will of the
people's original video
so i don't want to give away too much
that's cool but we have one that ends
with like an explosion yeah and then
the explosion reveals one of the scenes
from the original video so it's like
filling in the gaps plus the i always
want to stress we have a full storyboard
for like two different songs and uh in
terms of the videos and we have
character backstories for like
novelizations or video games and stuff
too because it's like the most
successful cultural things expand the
universe right yeah we've got these
we've got these ideas for uh you know
these characters their backstories what
we can do in terms of video games card
games graphic novels film and all that
stuff
you know and maybe it sounds grandiose
to a certain extent but just so people
understand
you look at the success of the marvel
cinematic universe you look at the
failure of dc and obviously
you know harry potter universes are what
you should be aiming for you should just
be trying to do like hey i'm gonna make
a song so so i've said this for months
that we were working on sequels to the
song the idea was to take stories from
within this universe and then make
something bigger out of it and that's
what we are doing we've actually already
run marketing campaigns over the last
year and this year so uh just to stress
how much we're putting into this
all right
coulter wagner says are you guys
planning on publishing things like
fiction fantasy and poetry as you build
culture yes
absolutely hell yes we already have a
book out tales from the inverted world
we have uh the second book is is nearing
completion and it is is a hundred times
better than the first book this is crazy
this next book there were death threats
you know people are threatening to you
know kill this is this shane yeah dude i
talked to him a few days ago i'm excited
to see so
we've got uh we got a bunch of cool
stuff i don't know i don't know how much
i should reveal i can probably just say
this no big deal the next series is
court is of course ghosts of the civil
war goes to the confederacy and uh
he went down to look for the lost
confederate gold in in georgia and found
a whole bunch of crazy ghost stories
sasquatch ufos and all the stuff in
between so there's like the story of
chasing after this lost gold to uncover
the mystery and then all the weird stuff
in between is each chapter but then
we're also looking at stories in chicago
with you know the 1920s the gangster
stuff al capone
you've got a whole bunch of crazy
chicago ghost stories and then we've
we've
we've got plans for all the stuff you
know coming out because we plan
shane and i were talking about if if
land can harbor pain if like the land
can actually
experience pain that then causes like
you know reproductions
really like i don't know i don't know
about that that's pretty far out there
for me but ghosts interesting
interesting
it is wild
paxton says tim is always saying he
could call out a bunch of celebrities
why not
um man
it's it's it's up to individuals too i
struggle with this too yeah
well for one so i have a couple uh
people that i consider friends yeah who
are extremely extremely famous
and their attitudes you know they don't
just come out and be like i voted for
trump and he's the best they come out
and they say
i've thought about coming out in support
of trump publicly but it means that my
family would suffer to a degree that i
can't handle and then i say that sounds
very cowardly and they say there's
nothing i can do about it and it's not i
can't i can't be the person to force
someone to do that yeah a lot of them
try to blame it on somebody else like my
spouse just can't deal with it you know
i can't do that to her that was never
part of the deal whatever it is and it
just at the end of the day you know what
you're going to have to do in the long
run is going to be a lot harder than
doing this so i'll just make your choice
one of the biggest to live with it one
of the one of the biggest musicians in
the world
having a huge party in los angeles with
a whole bunch of record exhaust record
record execs and celebrities and then i
was like they were like you got to come
out and party man people hear fans and
i'm just like i just find that hard to
believe because like why aren't you guys
just tweeting to your millions of
followers and just saying yeah enough
now truth be told these aren't people
who are saying the opposite they're not
coming out and supporting black people
so that's what i always tell people
they're like who's conservative in
hollywood i was like check their social
media and see who's not virtue signaling
right 99 of the time they're
conservative that's actually a
conservative thing to do is not tweet
out your thoughts not even necessarily
conservatives no yeah not and it's
probably the wrong word but they're just
in general they're very anti-leftist you
know they could be in more libertarian
ideology or whatever it is but they're
they're not fans of the democratic party
yeah
john l says my word for the new system
they're trying to push is socio-fascism
i don't know if that's the right word
though too many words so so let me let
me break it down communism was a
specific reference to
that time period about controlling the
means of production yeah the means of
production mean very different things
these days fascism was was very
traditionalist so it had a lot to do
with traditional you know traditional
rigid traditional authoritarianism
that's not necessarily what they're
doing right now yeah there's no strong
fascist movement in the united states
that's a lie the media is just
pretending there is there isn't there's
also necessarily a singular communist
system because
you have capital as the means of control
so it's this weird and it's not
capitalism yeah obviously it's a
distortion of capitalism but it's so
it's a weird combination of all of the
worst elements of communism fascism and
capitalism you know together together
yeah yeah and technocracy can we call it
like neapolitan ice creamism or just
like we do need a name
coconut yeah coconut ice cream really
bad isn't it i think that's what we're
living in like really bad
i'm set on technocracy at the
moment i mean it's a cool word but it
doesn't fully describe it you know i've
actually said maybe a better description
is we're the american ccp now because
the ccp operates in a similar way we're
just early in the infancy of it where
like they haven't fully come out and
been naked you know
honest about what they really are but in
sort of beginning stages of like hey you
know we're starting to take control of
everything and you know you better like
it you know you're going to own nothing
and you're going to be happy about it
all right rocky service says georgia
viewers please call your state senator
and demand they pass constitutional
carry bill sb 319 that sounds fantastic
and they say also bigfoot is real
well if you listen to chicken city
you'll often hear us complaining about
sasquatch
yeah
it's kind of a relatively sheltered area
so the uh sasquatch are safe from
predator predators in this area i'm
going to claim the fifth on this i
haven't have no uh information about
sasquatch
his existence or non-existence i have no
information robbie's actually the one
who brought saskatchewan over here
that's robbie actually it's sasquatch
i may have i may have did you get like
growing up from the battle star
galactica references starbucks yes and
thankfully i loved battlestar golem
you know i was like all right cool
that's fine all right c hennessey says
ian you couldn't discharge your student
loans from bankruptcy since 1976
written by our current president joe
biden it's only been been added to since
then oh thank you joe biden i thought i
remember uh george bush signings go
ahead say let's go brandon come on lgb
yep have y'all super chatted let's go
brandon
everybody should super chat let's go
brandon let's go i was actually going to
say that to you when you said it too but
i was like you know what it seems like
he really knows that maybe i'm wrong and
i was like no no i was right you were
wrong i should never stop myself like
that all right jeremy thomas says i
cancelled everything netflix disney plus
hbo max is all gone now i sub to tim
cass daily wire and blaze tv exclusively
that is awesome i deeply appreciate that
but as much as i can say like you should
try and get away from these products i
think it's just not realistic in in the
short term and in the short term we
should be saying everybody should be
writing making comics look some people
are like how can i write how can i make
a film just do it just start doing it if
everybody right now just said i'll try
and make something in five or ten years
we'll have a ton we'll have a ton of
stuff we'll flood the zone look at look
at this look at it's always sunny they
film their pilot with like a cheapo
camera yep and they just made it work
they figured it out this is the most
frustrating thing to me you know as a
filmmaker i used to always have people
come to me and be like how can i do what
you're doing and they'd say i just can't
do it because i don't have access to the
cameras and all this stuff i was like
um
i'm the child of a penniless refugee i
did not have some rich family i was not
part of a hollywood family i got a cheap
camera that i worked a minimum wage job
to get and then i snuck into shows i
filmed stuff of artists and i gave it to
them and they were like oh this is
pretty cool hey we'll pay you to do
something cooler and i built a whole
multi-million dollar company out of it
so you know if i could do that you can
do it and guess what you have the luxury
of having an iphone that has a 4k camera
on it go make something okay now they
actually have multiple uh
fields of view yeah so i think you know
go make something you have all the tools
you need natural light is a gorgeous
thing it's one of the most beautiful
things that you're given by god as a
filmmaker go use it what about for audio
what's the best thing for a young
filmmaker to make they have tons they
have tons of these little uh microphones
you can attach you know and i would
record it separately honestly that would
be my you know piece of advice if you
have no money and you're going on like
the cheapest bare bones operation record
it separately and they've got tons of
these little microphones you can use to
do it um just find the cheapest option
you know honestly if you're starting out
don't go don't go do anything you're
going to regret but go do something when
you say we're working separately that's
like you'll shoot the scene you record
it and then you um you do the scene
again and then just get the audio yeah
take the you'll have the raw audio on
whatever you film say it's an iphone or
whatever you know if that's what you're
starting on that's fine there's no shame
that you can make something amazing with
an iphone we've actually shot some music
videos with iphones for certain things
you know
and then you record the audio separately
so you can match the raw audio with that
usually do something like a clap to make
sure your time's on
um but yeah just just go for it make
something
i agree with him on that but i do i we
disagree on the netflix thing i say
cancel it cancel all of it okay so all
these people don't cancel i'm just
saying it's it's unrealistic to think
you're going to get a mass movement of
people instantly canceling because like
i was saying like i personally don't
have netflix i got rid of it over the
cuties and the big mouth thing the
scandals and we affected their stock
prices during the cuties thing big time
but there's a lot of people here who
have it so it's on the tvs already yeah
i don't know who these people are these
names fire them i don't like uh
i don't like that they hate you rhetoric
throw them in the moat i got that a lot
where they're like i these companies
hate you because they don't know who i
am or maybe they do but i got a lot of
this for the war in iraq they were like
they hate us for our freedoms hey ian
just so you know they hate you i got a
lot of being told that other people hate
me so like i don't like that as a
marketing technique well it's not even
it's just reality so from having lived
in that world and been around people in
hollywood and the way they think about
the country they they hate us they do
they hate they hate
like a plebian
yes 100 it's a total disregard we're a
different class and the thing that
always bothered me about this is i was
the only person kind of speaking up
against it because i didn't grow up like
they grew up most of the people who are
executives in hollywood they're from
hollywood families or they were raised
rich i wasn't so i come from this
different background that's like hey you
totally have no idea what you're talking
about guys
but that's they just have naked
disregard for how normal people live
their lives you know and they do
genuinely hate them if they had the
choice of i get to continue my life as
it is and the power i have and the money
i have um but to have that i need to
destroy all these people and everything
they love they'd press a button in a
heartbeat all right harley chuck says
tim you are not a centrist you are right
wing on the culture war have more left
wingers on instead of this circle jerk
oh no no i shouldn't have said that last
one cause i remember someone emailed
saying like my child asked me what that
meant a circle of jerks you're not
cutting each other you're growing up my
friends um nobody likes drinking no when
when we have on uh who did we have on we
had on was it royce when we talked about
redlining and blockbusting and the the
remnants of racist policies that
affected the united states
yeah you you don't get that typically
from conservative audiences and i get
called a leftist by conservatives and i
get called a right winger by the left
you actually last time you asked me a
lot of stuff that was not like typical
wheelhouse you know stuff it was like
hey let's think outside the box on this
you know i just think that uh if you're
on the left and you look to your right
you'll see me in a bunch of
conservatives if you're on your right
you look to your left you'll see me and
then you know slightly further away the
leftists be completely honest but it's
it's not an issue of uh right or left
it's an issue of truth or not so like
did joe biden engage in illicit business
dealings in ukraine that's a fact yeah
it's like at this point it's not even a
dispute you're just dealing in facts i
mean the hunter button laptops confirmed
by new york times the emails within it
show that there was nefarious family
dealings joe biden shortly after you
know uh barisma is telling uh roswell's
telling hunter biden like we gotta end
these investigations joe biden goes and
gets the investigations ended you got to
be a certain kind of special if you're
like those have nothing to do with each
other you have to be a major apologist
they shared bank accounts joe and hunter
shared but come on and so the problem is
you'll listen to cnn and they'll be like
there's no evidence it's true and
they'll be like okay they said it so
it's true it's like bro when we talk
about these things i pull the stuff up
and that is why you were a right-wing
extremist you're pulling up facts how
dare you
jeez man all right sid henry says tim
can we go grab korean barbecue in
northern va and make fun of woke people
with you and the temcas crew maybe csgo
after
uh you know what maybe we usually like
we'll go and grab dinner like every
other weekend with like a bunch of
people from the house the people who
want to go i shouldn't say from the
house but from the from the company
people also don't seem to understand
this is the weirdest thing there's an
assumption that people live here when
there's like four people who live in the
house out of like 30 employees and it's
it's like half of that is me yeah but
they're like all the people must live
that's like it's an office man there's
like a there's like a one of the rooms
is just a bunch of computers the
basement is just work stuff yeah
skatepark here but you know people
typically do not live here
they have houses in their own apartments
it's more like an office building
all right
let's see patrick reed says you and mark
levin should simulcast your eight
o'clock hours as you are both on live at
that time that would be a good show it
would take some coordination to make it
happen but it would be cool
maybe i don't know we don't do dylan
shows and i think the jon stewart andrew
sullivan uh
show is a really good example of why
i think you know everyone's roasting jon
stewart for making an episode called the
problem with white people because jon
stewart's totally fallen
you know oh that's sad
but uh andrew sullivan i think did a
really bad job a really really bad job
with um
he was not prepared for any real
conversation about systemic racism
critical race theory and so he just
looked confused in my opinion and then
he got called racist the whole thing was
just awful
you know
he should not have gone on the show to
me to be honest if you get hit up
anybody any personality gets hit up by
any talk show and they're like we would
like an expert on woke issues to come
and have a debate you'd be like oh yeah
you know the wrong person james lindsay
his email yeah go talk to them
exactly man narcissism gets in the way
of good decisions all the time
and that's one example of it you know i
always say with cnn like cnn has an
absolute uh pattern that they they kind
of project out when they go and book
guests and it's let's find the person
who is the least qualified to answer
these questions who's a republican and
let's bring them on to at to answer them
you know and they do that to make us
look stupid they never bring on the
people who could go and just shred them
on the issues yeah i'd like to see more
chris ruffo i remember him giving a
pretty experience those awesome succinct
uh explanations and that i haven't seen
him as much as i'd like to yep jerome
morrow says one of your will of the
people sequels could be post nuke when
the tim cast crew have moved into the
underground bunker and then evolved into
chuds
well i will say
that uh
the two songs because i'm not going to
give you the full story boards that we
have for them already the that are
nearing completion the first one is a
song about an insular moment in the
revolution between a father and his son
and the second one
is about
a kid who uh
you know grows up in civil war and
dreams of escaping and fleeing and
there's there's like the stories have
they basically have some some sort of
twist well the one about his dad and his
uh son i'll just say this the storyboard
is like memento you see the movie
memento yeah then the next one is just a
story with a great revelation but um
following the last one let me just say
post-apocalyptic is absolutely in the
works for uh for what we're writing
because when when if you watch will of
the people the song
you can see the time develop
technological advancements the first
scene is a little kid there's posters
the last scene is tvs and computers
because we're showing you know time is
advancing which means
there will come a point when war in this
cycle eventually results in the
i'll just say this fermi's paradox the
great filter we've got we've got a lot
of plans for all these songs i think
we've got like
40 songs
a lot so this is what we what we do
we're putting together these ideas of
what's going to follow follow this
there's like 40 different songs and
there's probably like a hundred
different riffs and chord progressions
and then we start dropping off and
eliminating like we don't like these
ones these are these are not as good as
these ones this one's way better and
then we end up keeping like 10.
so but in terms of the actual songs we
have a lot of songs
you know because a lot of them are
simple pop structure songs and things
are more complicated
but that's how it goes you know i don't
want to really reveal too much about our
plans yeah that's how i feel about it
too yeah i don't like saying things
unless
you're like trump in that way well this
is what really bothers me about what's
happening with the with the muse video
um
what what i've shown already is not even
the extent to which you know outside of
the video
i personally feel as a shot for shot
remake yeah it was like if someone was
going to make a live
a live movie version of our will of the
people they made it the same thing
theirs is called this will of the people
it shows uh uh hooded figures
throwing ropes to pull down statues like
that's literally i feel your frustration
the number of times my work has been
stolen from
by major labels and huge artists
is massive but the problem is is in my
case i was always signing deals with
these major labels and they buy you out
basically of of your rights and so you
can't go sue over it but yeah you can
yeah i own all the rights and people
need to understand like
some people have said you don't own this
individual idea this individual idea
it's like that's not what happens in
court when you go to court they they
look at the full picture like yeah you
you know if you baked a cake and then it
was you know the collection of all the
different kind of icing sure i don't own
the idea of icing but we we made this
one particular thing grouped together
yeah but i want to stress another point
i can't reveal literally
every single thing about what's going on
behind the scenes but i just want to say
what we've talked about in terms of what
they did copy
is not even the full picture because
they've copied more and we have to have
like i have to have lawyer meetings it
it appears that they copied just more
than the than the artistic work the
business strategy around it there's
other elements that like wow are
identified that have been like there's
there's first of all people have already
looked at the the videos and been like
yeah come on like
same color scheme same character uh
depictions same throwing of ropes same
name and then there's also business
elements
that are extremely similar not to
mention the weird thing about they
posted it on my birthday yeah which is
weird but i don't want to get too much
into that that's awesome dude because we
have some but
the birthday thing may be
i swear the guy watched the show and was
like i love that too i love tim pool i
need to know his birthday that is our
release dates
is it is it normal to announce an album
five months before releasing it no no
that's weird
that's weird
that's a tornado so yeah what is that
tornado warning yeah not for here oh oh
for
real be safe everyone because i don't
know this but you've done a lot of work
in music and music videos and stuff and
you're saying it is strange for a band
to do an album announcement announcement
five months before release yeah you see
they announced the album five months
before they're putting it out and they
announce it on my birthday that is weird
i will say that is weird that's a that's
a long time before you put an album out
now would artists know they're gonna do
that five minutes in advance yes but
that's always kept you know quiet and
it's something that it's in the planning
stages you know where we're meeting with
the label and going through okay what it
what are we gonna do what's the creative
on this gonna be
you know it doesn't happen like that
where you publicly go out i wish i could
say i wish i could say more because
there's a lot more than just this but um
there's there's certain creative
elements that are publicly available
that we've
we've published that are also
in my opinion in my opinion i see it as
identical
so it's not just this one video it's our
business development around it
and then five months before the album
comes out they post it on my birthday
with the name and the same video and and
that's crazy that's it right right right
yeah so we've got to figure that one out
and we're there's a lot of crazy stuff
happening so and we put our video out uh
we launched this project november 2nd
2020 and we were working on it before
then and i and and the first time i ever
played the song publicly uh actually the
first time i played the song publicly
may have been like six five years ago
when i was writing it but um the first
time the full version of the song was
played was june 19th 2020.
so this is before the artistic
development
but then um let me just say that
the entirety of the project it's not
just this one video that people need to
look at and
this i you know we'll have to we'll have
to talk about it when we talk about it
but if uh
you know
so far all we've done is mention it
there's gonna be a larger story here
that's what you're saying well yeah i
think i think uh
there's there's stuff working on behind
the scenes and there's stuff that is
publicly available but how do i how do i
say this not something you can pull up
and look for but yeah what is available
to the public with hundreds of thousands
of views
which is like yo
maybe a little cis
yeah like like very very very very you
know there's there's there's there's a
lot going on would i be the first member
of congress you know at least on the
republican side that said it's us
probably yeah all right all right all
right we got to go to that uh members
segment so instead of just harping on
about you know music and stuff you can
check out will of the people by
searching it on youtube and uh checking
out the music video if you haven't seen
it it's a short film so you got to watch
with intent because there's a lot of key
story elements in there that we're using
for the projects as we move forward like
the character's name is easily
discernable you can figure out who our
who our protagonist antagonist is so
check that out you can also check out
chicken city if you want to watch
chicken sleeping right now or throughout
the day you can follow me at uh you can
follow me at tim cats you can follow the
show at timcast irl head over to
timcast.com and become a member because
we're going to post that members only
show at uh just about an hour or so
robbie did you want to shout out social
media or anything else website yeah
definitely starbucks2022.com if you want
to get involved in the campaign we need
people to volunteer from all over the
country make phone calls if you live in
tennessee we need you to door knock with
me
but donations matter a lot because i'm
not taking that corporate money so
people powered grassroots matters and if
you want people who are actually going
to shake up and change the system you
got to put something behind it you know
and that's time money energy whatever
you can do but then on social media you
can find me everywhere at robbie
starbuck robby starbuck and when you
guys go over that will the people uh tim
poole video leave a comment with my name
on it i uh have some harmonies for that
song that i didn't record just one of
the people yeah go to tim's video and
just be like hey ian sent me put in the
comments well ian's got harmonies in
bright eyes dude i got harmonies on will
the people but we recorded it before i
had them fleshed out so when we play it
live i have a few that are pretty cool
here's here's a random fun fact in the
last album of the used
um
i there's some background vocals of me
on a couple of the songs because i was
at john feldman's house while they were
recording it
and uh i forgot what we were even
meeting about but um me and my wife
landon our vocals are on hers more
prominently she actually
is like singing something you know just
herself she was like doing something
with uh burp but yeah that's a random
fact it's a random info her name's on
the album mine's mine's not though yeah
bright eyes is liz clutch i mean i sang
on that one pretty pretty overtly and
man it sounds nice yeah that's blended
carter is a genius thank you
yeah bright eyes is hot yeah it's
getting good oh that's good
pete is just amazing drummer man
he is that uh we really enjoyed having
him as well thank you very much for
coming this evening star uh robbie
starbucks starbucks she's going to
battle star galactica starbucks
thank you for coming starbucks i'm sorry
don't blame me you guys may follow me on
twitter and
mines.com at sourpatchlets i also have
my own little site called
sourpatchlids.me
we will see all of you over at
timcast.com thanks for hanging out bye
guys
you